this is Joo podcast number 420 with Eko
Charles and me Joo willing good evening
Eko good
evening I chocked both my hands and took
a few breaths I didn't think at all
about my position or how I felt I just
carried forward on
autopilot left hand crimped another side
pull left foot jammed into a lower crack
somewhat sideways right foot came up
high by my waist and towed into a tiny
scoop the tension between my left hand
right foot created stability and I
raised my right hand up to a very small
but down pulling crimp my left hand
palmed down on the wall below me and I
raised my left foot extra high onto a
very sloping
shelf as soon as the foot was placed I
drove down with it and stood up the Thum
thumber cling with my left
thumb the hold was an upside down Ripple
maybe an inch long and a few millimeters
wide so small that it would never
qualify as a handhold
except for the fact that most of my
weight was on my feet I placed my hand
perfectly my thumb going into the more
sloping part in order to leave the
better inch of space for my index and
middle fingers to curl
over my right foot sneaked in and
matched next to my left and my left foot
kicked out leftward to a slippery black
knob the whole route came down to the
next four moves the hardest of the whole
sequence my right hand came into my left
and I removed my index and middle
fingers which had been stuck to the wall
only by the tension between my right big
toe and my left
thumb my right thumb took the fingers
place on the good part of the Ripple and
my left hand shot out left to grab the
sloping
loaf I squeezed it for all I was worth
and moved my right hand back to the
initial down pulling
crimp I was in an iron cross fully
spanned between the two holds right foot
through to the sloping dish hips open
left foot across to a tiny chip chalk my
right hand break it into the top of the
loaf now I was set up for the karate
kick though I spent no time thinking
about it my right foot came into the
crucial small Edge perfectly placed to
provide counter pressure when I kicked
my left foot
across I subtly switched the position of
my left hand making it feel slightly
more secure as I squeezed my two hands
together and crushed the loaf as if on
autopilot my left foot shot out
perfectly perpendicular to my body full
extension 3 feet to the
left it hit the far wall of the corner
exactly where it needed to be what used
to feel like a desperate falling kick
now felt like an easy foot
placement my feet felt welded to the
wall months of stretching paid off as I
brought my left hand to the crack next
to my foot my right hand switched to
palming downward and I felt secure
balanced between my left foot and my
right palm I reached my left hand up to
a big
Edge and I was
done I was through the boulder
problem I felt the flood of elation or
maybe just relief I was suddenly aware
of the World Around Me Again including
the cameras fixed to the wall on either
side of me I said something like oh yeah
into the camera in front of me I started
laughing I romped up the final few easy
moves to faint to the faint ledge
above I stood on the ledge for a minute
breathing hard
exultant I knew that somewhere in the
meadow 2300 feet below
Mikey was watching me through the long
shot I pumped my fists over my head
facing the meadow wondering whether they
saw me for once I was somewhat glad that
I had an audience I felt like a hero I
still had 10 pitches up to 512b above me
but I felt like I'd cleared the final
hurdle now it was just cruising to the
finish line
and that right there is an excerpt from
a book called alone on the wall written
by Alex Honnold with David Roberts Alex
Honnold is a rock
climber
and a legend in the climbing World who's
accomplished amazing feat of climbing
free solo climbing which is climbing
with no ropes and no protection of any
kind and a lot of this by
himself started with no Fanfare in 2007
2007 as a young climber he free soloed
and again that's that's no ropes no
protection he free soloed astroman and
rostrom and yose which are two legendary
climbs and then a year later in 2008 he
was the first person to free solo
moonlight bustus moonlight buttress in
Zion National
Park and he did that on April Fool's Day
and when it word got out that he had
done this some people
thought that that it was a
joke that it was just a April Fool's
joke because who would climb that
without a
rope well he would and he did and he
didn't stop there also in 2008 he free
soloed the regular Northwest Face of
half
doome which is 2,000 feet of rock
straight up out of Yus Valley
he was the first person to do that as
well and then he started getting a
little bit more mainstream attention he
was featured in a movie called alone on
the wall which I saw when it came out
some little rock climbing Festival here
in San
Diego and it was it parts of it are hard
to watch if you've been up at altitude
before but he continued to climb
continue to train continue to
learn and
continue to accomplish Feats in rock
climbing eventually on June 3rd 2017 he
made the first free solo asent of the
free ride route up yose's lcap which is
3,000 ft almost 3,000 ft of vertical
Granite jolting straight up out of the
valley and that Pursuit was captured in
the Oscar award-winning movie
called free solo by Jimmy chin and a few
days later he and another renowned
climber Tommy calwell Caldwell uh broke
the speed record up the nose of
elcap completing in an hour 1 hour 58
minutes and 7 Seconds the first people
to do it under two hours and he still
hasn't stopped he continues to push the
envelope and rock and now Alpine
climbing he has a podcast called
climbing gold he has a charity organ
ganization a master
class the hanold foundation which helps
people around the world that need access
to solar energy and incredible things
being done all the time by this
individual and it's an honor to have
Alex here with us tonight to talk about
his experiences and Lessons Learned Alex
thanks for joining us man awesome to
meet you thanks for having me that's the
biggest intro I've ever heard I'm like
I'm honored
uh I when we started talking about
having you on and Ekko was not too
familiar with rock climbing and I just
broke out the section of you doing the
boulder problem uh in on
YouTube and he was like oh my God what
is going on I said yeah this is this is
the next level
of it's the next level of human
achievement and I've been whenever
people ask me about this I think
that that run up uh free riter that you
did I I can't think of a of a bigger
sort of physical human achievement for a
human being to do I don't know I I can't
think of one if I do I'll I'll let the
world know but
that was just an incredible thing to see
no I appreciate it
um so I I hadn't heard that excerpt well
I mean obviously I wrote that excerpt at
but ien about it then hearing I was like
I'm kind of gripped so exting it's all
that like that's the exact Crux bet was
like I remember every move I like oh it
gives me little tingles exciting how how
many times did you do that move before
you did it that time so many I mean I
practiced a lot like a hundred like a
thousand yeah uh probably like a hundred
or more I mean I think I had a day where
I repelled down from the summit and then
did it 10 times in a row um and then
keep repelling you know a couple days
like that mhm but yeah I've done it a
lot and more importantly i' done every
variation of it where I fail you know I
tried every different permutation of
like these feet but those don't work and
then different feet and those don't work
and then different hands and you know
every version of it so I failed on like
every other version and then practiced
the the correct way a bunch of times as
well the one that finally worked yeah
well I mean there you know you could
make other ways work but you want to
find the best way yeah you do it's weird
too when you cuz I saw the movie in the
theater
and you still don't get the sense I mean
it gives you a good sense and but you
just can't duplicate what 2,000 or 3,000
feet looks like in a theater you can't
maybe I don't know I didn't see an IMax
IMax it uh I mean yeah it's not the same
as being there but it was very
impressive yeah I mean seeing eity in
IMAX I was like this is awesome yeah I I
didn't see it an IMAX but man it you you
can't just capture like the ground is so
far away that it's like the first time I
went parachuting when the when the ramp
of the of the aircraft goes down the
ground is so far away that it's not it's
almost you don't get that sense of
height almost cuz it's so far away and I
kind of got that feeling when I was
watching uh free solo in the theater I
was like man and believe me like my my
Palms are sweating like everybody else
but I was sort of like I know I've been
I've been there I know what that thing
looks like I've walked around up there
and I you can't
quite transmit it in any other media
other than being there yeah no I agree I
think that even for a lot of people who
come to you for the first time it's hard
to appreciate the sense of scale because
they can stand in elcap meow and look up
at elcap but without really
understanding the scale of it they're
just like oh that's a big piece of rock
and then they see that you know if you
use binoculars or telescope you can
point out climbers up high and they're
like oh my God that little tiny tiny
Speck of color is a person up there
they're like that's crazy it is yeah
yeah cuz when you're up on the top l cap
you know the people are like little ants
down below like I mean like dots like
tons of little dots down there it's
really big yeah Yos is just glorious
it's a glorious glorious place and
what's crazy too is as crowded as it
gets in like I would always go camping
with my family up there and it's be so
crowded right but even when it's crowded
it's no it's not that big of a deal like
there's a big crowd there and then you
take four minutes of walking out a quart
mile off off the road and all of a
sudden you're like we're alone in the
wilderness we can die out here yeah it's
it's just an incredible Place hopefully
we don't um hype too many people any
more people to go there no I I think we
should actually I'm I'm strongly into
the crowds there because I basically I
think that nobody cares about nature or
protecting nature unless they have
positive nature experiences and I think
eity is such a great accessible place
for people to be all inspired you know
it's like and the thing is even when it
is crowded you can walk for 10 15 20
minutes and you can see no one cuz e is
a huge Park and when we about it being
crowded we mean the main loop on the
main road in the very center but the
whole rest of the park is totally empty
like I've done some very long day hikes
there like every couple years I'll get a
little be in my Bonnet to go out for an
adventure and do like a 50 mile like
solo Day hike sort of thing like big
circuits around the park and you can do
some of those big loops and see like
four people the whole day yeah you're
kind of like everyone complains about
crowding you're like if you get off the
beaten path it's very empty it's like
Wilderness as soon as my kids were old
enough we started going a little bit
more outside and we we have a hike that
we do that would we would not see
anybody maybe we'd see one other person
we'd go out hike out for the day spend
the night up on the mountain it's kind
of the opposite side of half doome so
you're kind of looking at half doome
it's that area but there we'd see no one
out there and this is to be in the
middle of the summertime and so yeah
it's big enough and challenging enough
on some of those hi hikes out of there
you can be switchbacks for two hours of
switchbacks uh but yeah just amazing
Place incredible um so look your your
life has been very well documented in
the movie if you guys haven't seen this
movie just go see the movie you're born
and raised in Sacramento you dropped out
of college when you were not you went to
Berkeley for what a year yeah
engineering at Berkeley for for long
enough to know that I shouldn't go to
college that's funny I was in the Navy
and the Navy sent me to college and when
I got back to you know CU I was in the
SEAL Teams and I go to college for 3
years and when I got back you know guys
would be like oh you know what what they
teach you there there and I was like it
taught me never ever ever ever get out
of the SEAL Teams ever cuz the SEAL
Teams is just such a fun job and then
you see what the rest of the world is
like and you're like no I don't want to
do that could take me back to where
where did they send you to college the
University of San Diego oh yeah okay so
you were still at the same same place we
still here in San Diego but you know
sitting in a classroom is was not
conducive especially going from a job
where you're outside I mean I always
joke like I I ain't put on a shirt for
work you know what I mean I was like a
35y old man making $80,000 a year and I
wouldn't wear a shirt like unless I
really had to most of the time just
walking around you know you're hanging
out prepping stuff and getting gear
ready it's just a great job it's outside
you're doing fun stuff shoot machine
guns jumping out of airplanes blowing
things up like what else would you want
to do well for me what else would I want
to do
um so you dropped out of college and you
just went full van life climber mode
yeah basically I mean that that
obviously losses over the the years of
sort of existential like you know
especially because when I started just
climbing full-time being a professional
climber was much less of a thing the
climbing industry is way smaller there
were way fewer gyms there were way fewer
climbers it was less obvious that you
could ever make a living as a climber so
I sort of thought I was just going to go
climbing for a few years and see what
happened and I thought that maybe I'd
become Mountain guide or get into you
know get into the industry in some way
or like do something Outdoors um but
then it sort of eventually translated
into into being a professional climber
but part of that's because the industry
grew up sort of with me I was going to
say you I'd say you got into the
industry at at this juncture yeah yeah
no for sure for now I'm firmly
entrenched you know now I'm
establishment but but when I dropped out
of college there just wasn't that much
of an IND I mean there was you know
there were the same outdoor
manufacturers and things like that but
there's just way fewer people rock
climbing it was just less of a less of a
thing
yeah did you do
contests remember that rock climbing
contest thing that was going on for a
bit I mean which one just the when it
was be televised on ESPN or something
and it would be speed races it was more
like an extreme sport type thing yeah
did you do that um not really so I did
youth competitions like you know same as
like little league or soccer stuff or
whatever um and I was I was fine you
know I I did well on the regional stuff
I got second in Nationals once but
that's only because the other really
good kids had already aged out and gone
on to adult competitions and was kind of
one of those things where I was like I
was I was good but I was never the best
and I wasn't wasn't dominating by any
means but um you know I was I was fine
and then yeah now basically was never
good enough to do the adult comps or go
on to because Europe has a really
wellestablished uh World Cup competition
scene and so there have always been a
lot of comps in Europe but less so in
the US and either way I just never quite
had the talent for it I was like and you
talk about like in the book and
basically you started free
soloing when you were a kid just like
cuz you didn't really want to talk to
the other kids or you're too shy to talk
to the other kids and say hey can I link
up with you guys yeah especially once I
started traveling a little bit like
living out of the van and going to
destinations um so like one of the
places I started climb was in Joshua
Tree outside of LA and um and at the
time like my then high school girlfriend
was going to school in Southern
California so it was kind of like oh you
go to Southern California you go to
Joshua Tree Joshua tree is also the sort
of a birthplace of climbing in
California it's like has a a lot of
climbing culture a lot of climbing
history there and so you know it's nice
to sort of test yourself against these
historic roots from the 60s and 70s and
' 80s and so you know I wanted to go to
a destination like Joshua Tree but then
you get there and you don't know anybody
and you know this is kind of like pre-
cell phones pre-social pre like there's
no easy way to connect with strangers
plus I was super shy and kind of a kind
of a loser and kind of a weird dude so
it's a lot easier just to cruise around
and you know climb things by yourself
than to like walk around the campground
talking to
strangers you know that's a weird thing
I I I have a kids I've written a bunch
of kids books and I have a kids podcast
and I I'll like take questions from kids
and one of the questions I'll get you
know it's like oh I basically like hey I
don't kids don't like me and that kind
of thing and and one of the things that
I kind of say back to kids that are in
that position is like
um being alone is okay like it's it's
okay to be alone and you can it doesn't
mean that you're bad it just means that
you haven't found any W in that going to
get along with
yet yeah I'm just so hung up on the
irony of you writing kids books when
you're surrounded by knives on this
table like this I feel like we're in
like a CIA offsite sort of thing like
this black box with knives everywhere
you're like yeah I write kids books for
fun holy
[__] well yeah the the the whole knife
thing is it just kind of got out of
control started with one fake knife from
Echo Charles and then I tried to one up
him and then we just ended up with this
we we actually did did at one point I
brought a pistol and then Eko was like
well I don't know if that might be a bit
bit much or whatever so I guess we
backed to we called uh a truce an arms
truce it's only bladed weapon only edged
weapons yeah after the axe too that was
like okay we got to hit the braks little
I brought an axe too no someone sent an
axe I think okay maybe you brought it
yeah cuz once we posted like a picture
of like a couple knives on the table
then people were like I want my knife on
the table yeah totally totally it's like
books and knives it's really interesting
contrast yeah I guess I guess it is sort
of Representative of my life in a way
books and knives that's kind of I like I
I went to colge when I when I did go to
college when the Navy did send me to
college I was an English major oh yeah
and and why why does the Navy want an
English major blowing things up well
believe it or not when you're in a
leadership position in the military you
have to write a lot and you have to read
a lot so you get directives that come
down and you have to be able to read
those almost like a lawyer reads a
document but they didn't let you take
any creative writing classes they're
like don't AR you making anything up
just doing non-stop reports you're like
adding little flourishes like CU a very
dramatic experience we
had um I could turn my after actions
report into romance
novel uh you have to write all the time
you have to write Awards you have to
write evaluations of your troops and so
I had been an officer and so I was like
oh I need to be good at this and so that
I just majored in English and of course
everyone thinks how the you know what
are you going to do what what are you
going to do after yeah what are you
going to do with your English what you
do with your English degree you idiot I
was like well I don't know I'm going to
eventually wrote a bunch of books
including kids books uh so very strange
I know it is a little strange my mom was
an English teacher too so I don't know
what that has to do with anything my mom
was an English teacher my dad was a
history teacher and and you like books
that's not that big of a surprise the
weird thing is bro I I did not read
growing up like I did not but you knew
how to read I knew how to read but I
wasn't a reader you know kids now I
don't know how much of a reader you were
growing up but some kids yeah some
people just read they read like crazy
and I didn't I was like outside throwing
rocks at like puddles you know just
banging sticks together like a like a
crom magnet man that was kind of that
was kind of so my wife and I have been
talking about this kind of stuff a lot
cuz we now have an almost two-year-old
and we're about to have our second child
and so we're talking about parent you
know I feel like parenting is just
starting now that our daughter's getting
old enough that you can actually parent
a tiny bit she's less of a blob and more
of a real person that does stuff but
it's interesting the you know I mean
what you're describing it's like how
much is nature versus nurture and I feel
like there's some Basics though where
it's like obviously you could read you
know your parents if you're being raised
by a professors basically like you learn
how to and I think I think about that
with climbing with my daughter where
even if she's not into climbing and she
doesn't become a climber that's fine but
she's for sure going to know the basics
she's going to know how to repel she's
going to feel comfortable doing all the
things and whether she chooses to or not
that's up to her but so I I've been
through this before um I I'm really
Jiu-Jitsu as you can see walked around
my gym like this Jiu-Jitsu has been a
huge part of my life and when my kids
were born and then being raised by me I
wanted them to be into Jiu-Jitsu I
wanted them to love Jiu-Jitsu as much as
I did I wanted them to get the gifts of
Jiu-Jitsu that I got and probably the
same way you feel like you want your
daughter to be able to have the same
thing that you got out of climbing this
amazing no that's the thing I don't know
if I want her it's not that I want her
to have I mean it'd be great if she does
but I just feel like there's a minimum
threshold of confidence that has to come
because that's part of being in the
family but whether she chooses to to be
into it or not that's up to her you know
if she's more into reading that's fine
if she's into music like great I think
the goal of parenting I mean I don't
know yet you've raised four kids but you
tell me but but you know is to help your
child find the thing that they love
doing but then there's certain things
that part of being in the family is that
she's going to be comfortable hiking
outside she going to be able to repel
off cliffs like that's just I mean you
can't do family activities if you don't
know how to repel yep that's you're
you're walking a thin line my my friend
cuz you're like oh they could I'll
support whatever they want to do as long
as they're repelling off of cliffs no
but you can you can be taking your kid
to soccer every weekend but then you
know when you go on family outings
you're still doing family stuff yeah in
in the same way I suspect your family
had a minimum requirement of like you
must be able to read and do well in
school or do whatever you know it's like
you've got to be minimum competence and
then beyond that you can do whatever you
want like blow things up it sounds like
you've got it dialed because what I did
was too much jiujitsu pushed it too hard
on them
and they went through a phase thank God
they're all like full-on indu jitu now
but they W they except for my my son
went didn't go he wasn't allowed to go
through a phase of no Jiu-Jitsu my
daughters went through a phase of no
Jiu-Jitsu my son was like no this is
what we're doing the minimum family
standard for the boy was like very high
six days a week of Jiu-Jitsu that seems
like a lot maybe it is it's too much and
and really the key thing and this is if
there's any ADV and I used to look we've
been doing this podcast for I think
seven years seven eight years and in the
beginning I wouldn't like give parenting
advice because my kids were what 13 15
whatever nine I was like the jury's not
out yet I might not know in a whole what
I'm doing uh I feel a lot more
comfortable now uh putting this out and
and giving advice around raising kids uh
the main thing is and this total Common
Sense unless you're an idiot parent like
I was is make things fun if you make it
fun if you they have fun then everything
is they just want to do it more and then
they get better at it and then when
they're better at it they like doing it
more because they are successful at it
it just becomes it's just a better way
to roll you don't want to be like like I
was we would
spend five hours on Saturdays and
Sundays here at this Gym
training no slightly psycho they
slightly psycho slightly psycho I'm like
I love climbing and I still don't think
I'm going to push push anybody quite
that hard yeah and and that's the cool
thing is eventually you know the kids
kind of will they're watching you all
the time and they'll see the joy that it
brings you and they'll see what you've
gotten out of it and how much you enjoy
it and they'll be like oh I want to try
that too and as long as you're not like
you need to do that again you need to
run that route again
totally Don't Go full psycho like I did
I don't recommend it it's a really hard
balance too because with your kids
you let's face it if I was like okay you
can you can plot out the perfect life
for your kid you could probably do a you
know a normal person could go okay
here's what you should do and here's how
you be successful and happy in life
according to what I think happiness is
you could probably plot that out pretty
well probably anyone
could but they're people and they're
they're yeah they have their own their
own thing that's what I I I always say
even as a two-year-old we're starting to
see that with our daughter which she's
kind of a fierce independent woman
you're like you follow your heart do you
do what you want to do yeah going to be
the way I explain it to adults now is
they're going to be who they are not who
you want them to be the more you just
open up your mind to that is the the
easier it's going to go actually I had
this idea that I think could be a good
book I'll just give it to you because
you obviously write books you can have
it but um but it's a concept I've I've
invented I think that that I'm calling
Downstream parenting where you just do
everything with the current you know you
just go with the current like everything
that's like chill you know within
grounds of sort of safety and and you
know some basic constraints but every
time I find myself trying to stop my
daughter from doing something or wanting
her to do a certain thing I'm like is it
because I want her to do that thing or
is it because she actually needs to do
that thing you know I'm sort of like you
know what if like if she wants to do
something and that's not dangerous and
it's not going to like cause harm to the
property or whatever then like let her
do the thing it's Downstream just go
with the current and part of that I
think is because she's young enough that
you can't reason with her anyway and
like teach her things in exactly so I'm
kind of like you know why fight it all
the time just like let it happen let it
happen go with current and the minimum
standard that you talked about that that
can be used as well especially it's
really important just like in leadership
it's really important to explain to
people why you need to do something so
if you've got your daughter and you're
like hey you need to know how to do this
stuff oh well I why do I need to be able
to you know uh repel repel off a cliff
why do I need to be able to do that and
just well there's a couple reasons
number one you don't know what kind of
situation you're going to be and number
two like the confidence that'll bring
you number three the opportunities that
will this will give you and the that
you'll have to so you just have to have
some reasonable things number three the
odds are she's going to have to rescue
her dad at some point gets into
something weird and she's got to go run
back to the garage and get a rope and
sort him out yeah and then and then I
was recently having a conversation
where you know what if you can't what if
you don't have a good why for instance
like clean your room why why do I need
to clean my room and you say well and
there's some legitimate reasons like
well if you need to find something
you'll be able to find it quicker if
your room is clean or if the there's a
fire in the house and the the firemen
show up and they're tripping and falling
over your toys that could make it really
hard for them and and those are both
those are a little bit of a stretch and
so in our case it's you don't want to
make habitat for the
cockrides you get cockes in kind of like
you just don't want like creepy crawlies
and all your stuff so so you can find
legitimate reasons and then occasionally
you find something where you don't have
a legitimate reason yeah but actually so
I'm I personally basically don't do
anything like so I
leave like I'm in my pajamas right now
because I'm like I'm staying indoors
today I just stay in my comfy clothes
all day and so basically at my house I
have my pile next to my bed of my
outdoor clothes which are really really
dirty and then my indoor clothes which
are my pajamas and I just alternate you
know throughout the day I go for my
pajamas to my outdoor Clos my pajamas
again and my wife is just giving up
fighting on it it's just I have my two
piles next to the bed that's all I use
and I use the same for like a month or
two and it's totally fine and I'm sort
of like I suspect that our children will
get away with sort of the same routines
cuz like I've I've already done away
with like like my family was to like you
take out the trash every day on trash
day like even if it's not totally full
and I'm like well that seems stupid
because it's not full and so now at our
house you know some of the trash cans
get emptied like once every six or eight
weeks or something because they never
fill and you're like that's fine I'm
like you know my life is easier for it
well you're already in the place where I
was going which is yeah Downstream this
what I'm saying it's all downam if you
can't give your kid a legitimate reason
why to do something yeah then don't do
it then then what's then ask yourself go
look in the mirror and like wait is this
just my ego that wants the room to be
clean for control sake like you're just
telling them to do a thing because you
want them to do the thing you're like
that's douchy cuz you wouldn't want
somebody else to doing that to you
yeah yeah it's like it's like the Golden
Rule the 2-year-old you know it's like
don't tell her to do something that I
don't want to do yeah yeah uh as you're
pursuing rock climbing you drop out of
college it's not really a there's no
real future in it at the time how are
you explaining that to people how you
explain that to your parents how you how
how you talking to explaining that was
it the same thing that you just said
like hey I'm going to do this for a few
years and I'll figure something else out
kind of I mean when I initially dropped
out of college I wasn't dropping out of
college I was just taking a semester off
um and actually at the time I'd
qualified for the Youth World Cup so
like this competition in in uh I gotten
second in National so I qualified for
international so I was like oh I'll take
a semester off I'll go to Europe and do
this competition and then you know and
then travel around and climb a little
bit and then I just never went back to
college I was like turns out traveling
and climbing is you know was was more of
my thing than than than class when did
you realize you were good uh it's Tak I
don't know I'm like it's taken a very
long time and even then it's like what
is good cuz climbing is a really broad
broad Sport and so most of my friends
and peers who are you know professional
climbers are serious climbers are sort
of better than me at lots of other
things or other aspects of it and so you
know I still struggle with that but I
mean obviously now I'd accept that I'm
much better than average but but still
way worse than most of my friends at at
many things so you're kind of like well
still always working at it did you did
you when you were trying to get better
when you were trying to improve
was it just based on like hey I'm
looking at a route I I can't do it right
now I'm going to work until I can do
this route and you're just doing that
over and over again is that yeah that's
that's a big part of it and then part of
it is reading books climbing history you
know old school climbing media like VHS
stuff where you're like oh that's cool
somebody did this thing you know I mean
just basically yeah what you're
describing like inspiration of whatever
kind leading you to to push yourself
until you can do that kind of thing and
when you're looking at you go to Joshua
Tree and there's a that you try and
climb and you can't climb it you
fail do you do you go back a month later
you go back a month later you go back a
month later and finally you're able to
pull this thing off yeah that's kind of
the idea I mean the thing about climbing
is that it's hard to know what failure
means because you fall off Roots all the
time when you're climbing with a rope
this is like normal climbing if you're
like bouldering when you have pads or
you're climbing with ropes and you know
you have protection that catches you
that's kind of normal day-to-day like
your bread and butter climbing I mean
you fall off routinely like that's part
of the process and so you only really
fail if you give up and you walk away
from it and you never come back but
falling off is is fine that's like
that's that's normal it's just that you
know like you don't characterize that as
failing per se you're just sort of like
oh I'm still training I'm still
practicing I'm still learning on this
route and then eventually you do it so I
mean the the mindset is always I it's
all sort of cliche you know like growth
mindset sort of stuff but that's but I
think that's sort of an intrical you
know that's sort of foundational to
climbing is that you're always like
anytime you fall off something you're
like oh that's fine I'm like practicing
I'm learning I'm refining the moves I'm
figuring it all out and eventually I'm
going to do it and you could would you
were younger could you track your growth
though you're like oh four months ago I
couldn't do this route and now I can I'm
better now yeah yeah I mean it's always
so much more fun in a sport when you're
at the the beginning of the growth curve
you know it's like you improve really
quickly and yeah it's a little more
painstaking now did you do did you like
exercise specifically did you start
start to do fingerboarding in your
bedroom or anything like that when you
were younger trying to get better um no
so actually I mean I grew up climbing
before there were fingerboards really I
mean some people did but it just wasn't
a thing that you could just buy online
like you can now um I mean there wasn't
even online to buy to buy the things but
uh but yeah I mean you know the most
elite climbers still use tactics like
that but it wasn't normal enough for a
Suburban kid growing up in Sacramento to
to know about that really but um but I
had a pull out bar in my door frame like
so through high school I was doing 150
pull-ups before bed every night it's
just like this will make me a better
climber in sets of like 10 20 30 but um
in retrospect it didn't really make me a
better climber but but I was able to do
one arm pull-ups after that I was kind
of like all you do a Sher pull-ups I can
attest that I was always really into
pull-ups and would do hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of pull-ups and it
did never translate into my climbing I
go climb with somebody that actually
knew how to climb and you just be a
total idiot like your strength it means
nothing just like any any sport you know
you look at these Sports whatever they
are and you think oh that that I could
probably do that no there's so much
technique behind it it's totally
ridiculous and climbing is well I think
climbing is just one of those many
sports that people look at it and they
don't realize how hard it how technical
it is yeah how much technique matters
how how much subtlety there is in the
body position the movement how you place
your feet how you adjust your hips like
yeah there's a lot to it yeah there's
way more to it than it sort of like
boxing right boxing you think are just
throwing punches but there's so much
going on there Jiu-Jitsu you look at you
go oh there's a lot going on in it you
can see that you don't know what's
happening right and rock like oh hold on
to that thing okay I I I can as a as a
primate I can understand what that means
kind of like as a primate I can
understand I punch punch in the head and
it it makes sense an an Uma plada in
Jiu-Jitsu doesn't make sense to a
primate it's like one of those things
you go this doesn't I I there's
something I don't understand what is an
Uma PL it's just like like a a move with
your body where you're taking the
person's arm and you're wrapping your
legs around a certain way and moving
your hips like it's a very complex move
that you would never think of as a
primate you wouldn't think of it as how
to win a fight and it's the same thing
with boxing you look at boxing over
they're just swing you go if you have
ever boxed against a good boxer someone
that was like a Golden Gloves boxer or M
much less a pro or an amateur boxer like
I've boxed against professional boxers
you're an ID I I'm an idiot right I just
you're just getting touched like there's
nothing you can do about it and yet
people watch Boxing go move your head a
little bit and punch him in the head you
know it's there's so much going on and
that's what that's why you know the my
early experiences with climbing was like
oh I can do a bunch of pull-ups I can do
many pull-ups I will climb Rock and it
was like the most
ridiculous uh pathetic thing I was
telling you earlier I was climbing a
rock out in in Mission gour with one of
my buddies and I was like probably I
don't know know maybe 25 ft up something
like that and I'm coming over the top
like almost done and it was a sloping
kind of rock and I am gonna fall like I
am so freaking gonna fall and I I used
my face and like chin and face to like
secure and smear on the Rock and kind of
inch my hands up more and I was like
dude I am dumb I am really a dumb person
or you're Innovative you
know the face smear is a is a new kind
of technique
though though everybody's done things
like that when they get desperate enough
start wedging their body into things and
like oh God yeah yeah actually I ran
into somebody at the bassell cap this
season we were hiking down from from
something and uh he was climbing a sort
of notorious off with like a offsize
crack where his whole body's wedged in
and uh and he just described an
experience where he basically gotten
bouted and wound up uh clipping off his
helmet for protection like leaving his
helmet behind wedged in the crack with
the Rope slung around it as like well
maybe the helmet will catch me if I fall
which you're like the helmet's not going
to freaking catch you like you're for
sure going to die but now I think of
that as my sort of gold standard of or
you know the sort of low bar of like
things are going sideways would you just
like leave your helmet behind as as
potential protection be like like maybe
it'll catch me it's like a freaking
little plastic bucket you're like it's
for sure going to break you're going to
die not going to work out well yeah
that's not going to save you scary uh as
your like like going Moonlight buttress
which again go on if you're listening to
this go on YouTube and just go look at
Moonlight but and go look at what that
freaking thing looks like uh how'd that
come AC like what that's what what made
that sort of like this will be the first
big one well so that I mean it was it
was a logical progression in a lot away
so um so the first like big solos I did
astran and the rostom those had actually
been done in the mid1 1980s by this guy
Peter Croft who's a famous Canadian
climber and total Legend of e and so
he'd been a personal hero forever and so
there was kind of a road map as to how
to do that and those represented the
edge of big wall soing at the time
really like those were kind of the
biggest hardest things but so this thing
Moonlight butus is only slightly bigger
it's like almost the same size as astran
like roughly 1,000 feet tall but
significantly harder technically like a
harder number on it you know bigger
number so it's harder but the style
actually is is H very similar it's just
one crack feature that splits this but
straight up the middle so even though
it's harder which means your forearms
get more pumped like your muscles get
more fatigued but it's a but it's still
a similar style like the it still feels
secure like if your bones are locked
into the crack like you know basically
if you have the fitness for it you don't
feel like you're going to fall off you
know and and that's an important thing
when we're talking about free sing is
the differentiating between the
different styles because if you're
climbing a crack it means that your your
fingers or your hands or whatever your
feet are like wedged into the crack and
as long as you don't get too tired
there's really not a reason for you to
fall off and so and fitness is
relatively easy to build as a climber
whereas technique you know so but
contrasted against like say crack
climbing you have like face climbing or
like slab climbing with just a bald kind
of what you're describing a Mission
Gorge where you're just like crawling
over the top of some rock and so if
you're imagining climbing something
that's like a bald smooth blank rock no
matter how big your muscles are it's
still all about how carefully you
position your toes how carefully you
balance like how well you move your hips
you know like those are the things that
you can practice for sure and you can
improve that but you just can't train
the same way and you never feel safe
doing it you never feel secure
like no matter how strong you get it's
still going to be really freaking scary
so anyway Moonlight kind of hit that
that sweet spot where I was like this is
roughly the same size what I've done
just a little bit harder but harder in a
way that's secure and and controllable
and then that said I'd also just come
off several months of climbing in Indian
Creek in Utah which is like home to
these perfect splitter Sandstone cracks
like exactly the same style as what
Moonlight is and so I just spent three
months there where I'd basically done
every hard thing in the desert at the
time and was feeling like like a boss on
S you know I was like oh I feel good and
then you know but actually it was
interesting though because I had sort of
this nagging elbow injury at the time
and had been climbing less than I wanted
to be you know I wanted to just be going
full bore but I was kind of hurting and
so I'd have to like rest a couple days
and then I'd go out and do something
really hard and but then still be
hurting I was like damn it you know it's
really frustrating and so it's kind of
that good combination of being kind of
pent up and like antsy and chomping at
the bit but also feeling really fit in a
way and I think part of that led to
Moonlight where you're like I really
want to do something Rad but I'm kind of
hurting but I'm really good at the style
right now and so then Moonlight was like
the obvious thing the obvious thing uh
and I'd done it with a rope and a
partner uh two years before so I knew I
could do it I'd done it first try with
with his partner and you know like I
knew that it was a beautiful inspiring
like perfect route and like yeah right
style and everything did you do it a few
times before like immediately before
yeah so I went there by myself and then
I spent two days working on it
um and each day I basically climb the
whole route twice M so and and Moonlight
is also really convenient in that
there's a pave tours trail that goes up
the back the uh the the Angels Landing
Trail which is like one of the most
famous trails in the country or in Zion
anyway it's a really really cool Trail
but that goes up to the top of Moonlight
and so it's super easy to work because
you just stroll up this path and then
repel down the
face uh in in the movie alone on the
wall a guy says I don't know who it is
but he says um the most mind blowing
thing in climbing ever when when you CL
when you climb that um this is a weird
thing well at least from from the from
outside the climbing world it's a weird
thing so you climb rostrom you climb
astroman you climb Moonlight
buttress and you tell one of your bu you
basically tell your buddy that you
climbed it and then he kind of posts it
on the the
interwebs and that's sort of it like no
no one took pictures of you no there's
no video of
it I eeko and I were talking about it
yesterday like what is it about rock
climbing like if if I if I posted on the
internet today hey everyone just want to
let you know I squatted a th000 pounds
people would be like I believe it I
don't know I don't know if that's hard
or not but I think you could but the
rest of the community would be like we
want video we want to see we want to see
what you did we see you know we want to
come and check the weights like we want
to see the we want to measure the
weights to make sure this is true can
you squat 1,000 lb can anybody squat
1,000 lb yeah some people can but you
know it's say it's does the bar Bend
when you SC thous the bar definitely
bouns it's [__] up yeah but it's but
here you are you're doing you're
achieving these things and I it sounded
like uh Moonlight buess there were some
people that were like oh well you know
really like actually people were
skeptical not of the clim really but
because it was posted on on uh April
Fool's Day what you know people were
like oh that's a funny fake news story
and then and they're like wait is that a
real news story like what the [__] but
nobody ever was like oh we don't think
he did it people don't question it no
but I think climbing I mean there are a
few things going on I know what you mean
and that's starting to change a little
bit for climbing as well um where I
think if you posted like truly
outlandish claims nowadays people would
sort of expect video evidence or or
something or at least like a GPS track
or you know depending on what exactly
you were doing but I mean the nature of
climbing is that you're normally doing
the climbs in remote places without
service without people I mean
particularly with soing you know by
definition you're by yourself so you
know I mean you are really are just
taking people at their word I mean
that's a big part of climbing but part
of it is also that if people don't
believe you you can just go do it again
you know the rock is still there the in
the same way that if somebody doesn't
believe that you lifted 1,000 pounds
you're like oh I can just do it again
tomorrow or if not lift 1,000 you could
at least lift like 950 or something and
be like you know it's close enough that
you can imagine and then on a peak day I
did what I said I did yeah except for
it's well that's a little messed up
because close enough on a free solo
isn't but what I mean with with close
enough is that you know people can see
you so on other routes they can see that
you could do you know I mean in my case
I mean especially now I've done I've
done a lot of soling and and I think
maybe I I counted this I have a list on
my phone actually of of things that I've
done that are sort of first like what
you're describing with u you know
Moonlight and half doome and things like
that and so I've done something like 35
roots that were like firsts or things
that had been done before and of those I
filmed on roughly a third of them or
like went back and took photos on them
later or or like in the case of elcap
with the film fre solo you know we
actually it's a full-on documentary film
where they shot the real thing but so
you know there's maybe a third of the
things I've done that there's evidence
for and then there are the other
two-thirds that there's no evidence but
you know occasionally somebody would see
you or you occasionally you pass people
on the route like as you're climbing you
just climb over other people and they
just left being like [__] like what a
day you know like that's that's crazy
that must be the that must be the
craziest thing in the world being 2,000
ft up on a wall and have Alex Roll On by
like can I can I pass you guys yeah yeah
no I mean yeah it's funny what was the
climb where you borrowed somebody's
chalk bag yeah that was on the nose yeah
yeah I forgot my chalk bag what a bot
but yeah but I got it back to him I left
it on the tree for him at the top but so
he got back you know four days later
whatever when he got to the
top you mentioned that too you mentioned
it real quickly reenactment MH right
which I didn't even being like I said
like a a rock climbing sort of adjacent
fan guy I didn't realize that when I was
watching alone on theall the movie that
you those were reenactments yeah though
I mean reenactment I don't know if
that's even because you are up there so
long again you know it's like you're the
difference is just that you're only
soling key parts of the roote and you
know you're soing the things typically
you're choosing the parts of the roote
that look the coolest but feel the most
secure the things that you can do on
command cuz anytime you're doing it for
a camera you have to wait for the camera
guy to get in position and you're like
hanging there and then they're like hold
on got to change batteries and you're
like okay Tick Tock you know like I'm
getting pumped you know and then they're
like oh hold on got to change lenses and
you're like tick tock tick talk you know
like I'm my arms are tired so you know
it's not like you're exactly reenacting
like it's not like it's fake it's just I
it's not like you're
not thing whatever you're seeing like
you are seeing photos and video of
freeing
but it's normally construed you're sort
of portrayed as like this is the real
thing and you're like well this is
actually the day that we had the crew
and went back and shot though that's not
the case for the film free solo which is
like an actual documentary where we did
the real thing and there are a couple
other films like that where like
occasionally it makes more sense to
shoot the real thing but most of the
time it makes more sense to just go and
do it whenever it makes sense for you
weatherwise and fitness wise and
conditions wise and then to go back and
shoot whenever it's convenient for the
whole
crew this feels like the kind of thing
that would
make me I don't get mad but this feels
like the the kind of thing that would
make me mad like I get done with
something awesome they're like hey you
got to do it again because we didn't get
a good shot y well that's that's the
nature of being a professional though
yeah it's like being good at doing the
thing just makes you a good climber
being a good professional climber means
that you can then tie back in and do it
again and like get the crew up into
position and like deal you know I mean
to me that's like that's the nature of
being a professional well the also in in
these various movies they'll talk to the
camera guys or I've seen do iies about
the guys that were making the movies and
they'll all feel kind of the same way
that I feel they'll be like dude like
you don't have to do this section or uh
can you do that but they don't really
want to ask you and they don't feel
comfortable asking they don't want to
put like it they don't feel good about
it either well this is yeah that's
that's the challenge of shooting any of
this kind of stuff is that the crew
doesn't want to be there you don't want
the crew to be there everybody feels
uncomfortable depending and that's why
typically when you're re-shooting
something you choose the parts that are
the most secure you know basically the
safest M because you don't you want to
traumatize the crew like you don't want
to fall on a you don't want to die on a
work day you know like like I might be
willing to risk death for my personal
projects but I'm not going to risk death
to like get the get an ad for a jacket
or something you know you're like
whatever I don't know like you know I'm
up there like shooting photos of a chalk
bag or whatever and you're like yeah
isn't this a great shot you're like no
I'm not going to risk yeah exactly I'm
like I'm not taking any any risk for
that stuff it's it's wild I was watching
uh I was watching you climb the Phoenix
right and you grabbed this photographer
dude like mourning of like hey you want
to go shoot me I'm gonna go do some
climbing he's like okay and then you
repel down into the Phoenix and then
like hey can you just haul all my stuff
back up and he has like an image of him
pulling up everything your rack your
harness and everything but your chalk
bag and this dude is you could see he's
camera sh he cam does this make him him
not a professional he like camera shaky
it was like freaking but what's weird
about that was like like you repel down
mhm the Rope is already on you it's like
a perfect top rope scenario for you to
do all your stuff and climb up there but
it's like no I'm going to do this and
sometimes you choose the challenge yeah
you choose the challenge but I mean
that's another interesting example
though because sometimes you film on
things because it's more convenient for
the experience itself because like if I
wanted to free Sol of the Phoenix but I
didn't have somebody with me didn't have
somebody shooting let's say then it
means I would repel down tie all my
stuff to the rope and the Rope would
just be kind of dangling behind you and
that would totally compromise the nature
of the experience because you know that
if you fell off you could just jump back
and try to catch the rope and maybe you
would maybe you wouldn't but but either
way you would feel like there the few
people in the world that like takes
takes comfort in the fact that well if I
fall I can possibly jump jump backward
and catch a 10 mm rope yeah but I mean
there are stories of people catching
ropes like that you know it can happen
it would require a degree of luck and
and you'd burn the [__] out of yourself
but but you'd probably you could
potentially survive that way and so it
would just change the the nature of the
experience and there's several solos
that I've done that I took photos or
video on because I wanted somebody there
like actually a different uh rout in you
somebody called Cosmic debris there
there still photos of it actually the
guy Mikey who you mentioned in the my
the exer from my book who was shooting
the long shot in free solo he um he's a
photographer and I've worked with him a
ton over the years but he I recruited
him once to shoot photos of me on this
crack because it's basically a crack to
Nowhere it just goes up this blank wall
and then just ends and so if you were
free soing you would just get to the top
and be like well now I just have to
climb right back down and it's really
really hard actually it's the hardest
thing that's ever been soing you
somebody grade wise uh like technically
and so you know I asked him to basically
go up there and like get into position
with the rope and his camera ahead of
time and then I could just show up
whenever I wanted climb it and then when
I was done we would just repel down
together God and you're like oh it just
makes the whole experience more doable
and you know I probably could have
rigged some other way to do it totally
alone but it just kind of makes sense to
have your buddy there with take a
picture
yeah this is Mikey in the down in the
meadow when you're climbing who's I
can't look at the camera he's looking
away gosh
uh half doome that was like the next
obvious thing yeah yeah basically it was
so halone was the next obvious step
because it was bigger and sort of more
rad like more intimida like just bigger
and more onping but actually it's graded
technically easier than moonlight so the
the the difficulty grade is technically
easier though the style as it turns out
is much less secure and and sort of more
difficult in a way but um it basically
just felt like the next big thing you
know it's only a little bit harder than
the roster man astran but it's but it's
like having the two of them stacked on
top of each other it's like really big
2,000 feet yeah and also I mean it's
2,000 ft high but it's 200 feet above
the valley floor so you're like 4,000 ft
up above e like feels feels very airy
you know you're up there you're like oh
this is it's pretty Mega bro 30 ft
sounds pretty big to me right now yeah
well honestly the difference between
like 50 ft and 1,000 ft doesn't start to
matter that much cuz like you know if
you fall more than 50 feet or so you're
going to die yeah but um I got to go to
the book on this
one this is so now you're like 1,800
feet up something you're almost the top
you have a little bit of a situation
we'll
say you say I climbed into the upper
Crux feeling good about doing things
legit and then I ground to a halt I'd
expected to find some sort of different
hold or sequence from the one I'd used
two days earlier which had felt pretty
desperate but perhaps I'd done it wrong
this time in the same position on the
same holds I realized there were no
better
options I had a moment of Doubt or maybe
Panic it was hard to tell which although
I'd freed the pitch maybe two other
times the year before I could remember
nothing of the sequence or holds perhaps
because there aren't
any it's very dramatic writing I'm like
oh God a gigantic old oval Carabiner
hung from a bolt about 2 in above the
pathetic Ripple that was my right hand
hold I alternated back and forth
chalking up my right hand and then my
left switching feet on marginal smears
to shake out my calves I couldn't make
myself commit to the last terrible right
foot smear I needed to snag The Jug I'd
stalled out in perhaps the most
precarious position of the whole
route I considered grabbing the [__]
with one pole I'd be up and off Taurus
oblivious laughter spilled over the lip
tons of people were up on top I was in a
very private
hell I stroked the [__] a few times
fighting the urge to grab it but also
thinking how foolish it would be to die
on a slab slide in and bouncing almost
2,000 ft to my death when I could so
easily save
myself my calves were slowly getting
pumped I knew I should do something soon
since treading water was only wearing me
out down climbing never occurred to me I
was going up it was just a matter of How
High one way or another but now real
fear seized me once again I took a deep
breath studied the holds in front of me
and tried to think rationally about what
I had to do although I never wanted to
be on that slab in the first place I had
to finish what I'd started without
invalidating my Ascent finally I
compromised I kept my hand on the
pathetic Ripple but straightened my
right index finger just enough for the
tip of my last pad to rest on the bottom
of the oval my thought was if my foot
blew I could snatch the [__] with one
finger and check my
fall
I smeared my foot stood up and grabbed
the jug no problem I was delivered free
from my little prison where I'd stood
silently for a good 5 minutes and I
hadn't cheated by grabbing the
[__] I took the final 5 S slab to the
summit at a near run 20 or more hikers
sat on the edge of the prep preus
witnessing my final charge but no one
said a word no yell no pictures nothing
maybe they thought I was a lost hiker
maybe they couldn't conceive of where
I'd come from or maybe they just didn't
give a [__] when I mantled onto the
actual top I was met with a flood of
humanity a 100 odd people spread across
the summit Plateau tourists ate lunch
next to me they made out took Scenic
photos people everywhere it was so
weird yeah so uh Half Dome you can you
can hike up Half Dome like a normal
person can hike can get permits and hike
up Half Dome and they got these cables
that you can kind of go up in between so
there's normal people up there though
that was written pre permitting system
so that's why it's funny because I
mentioned how crowded it was no no so it
used to be a zoo and now with the
permits it's way less zooy yeah because
nowadays it's rare to see so many people
on top at any given time because the
they permits um but anyway yeah hearing
that I was like I kind of forget because
they've been permits for quite a long
time now but yeah back then it was just
free-for all and so the cables would get
packed and there'd be so many people on
top which is it got slightly dangerous
and so they instituted the perming
system but so yeah and I bet people
didn't even like comprehend what it just
happened like you just show up they kind
of like oh it's yeah it's funny because
when you climb half doome with a partner
in climbing gear and you have all your
gear jangling on your harness as you get
over the top then when you get over
people like oh my God you know how many
days do you spend on the wall that's
incredible like what do you do but when
you top out free soling you know I don't
even have a shirt on I've got like
nothing sort of like like H you know
people like that guy looks psycho you
know like like kids don't make eye
contact you know it's like like who's
that guy you know it's like a whole
different
VI
um that's that's that moment right there
right where you're like kind of not
feeling the next move really is what it
is and though it's if you don't if
you've never done any rock climbing what
you're doing with your
feet I don't think I've ever even felt
freaking the way supposed to feel like
when I have rock climb you're so what
you're doing Echo Charles is you you're
taking your foot you got like rock
climbing shoes on but there's very
little to it's not like a step it's not
even like an edge it's just like Smooth
it's like a blank Ripple yeah and you're
just kind of I'm looking around the
table for something like comparable like
Ripple wise just but it's just like this
right here
tiny no I was like I was trying to think
about like this part of the lens you
know I mean like not on the edge but
like on the part that's just like
slightly slanted like oh if you just and
cuz climbing shoes are you know really
tight with like a precise Edge to them
and they have rubber that's like
stickier than than normal shoe and so if
you just imagine putting your big toe
against that Ripple and like pushing
against that and then sort of balancing
just right it's like it's all yeah but
that's what I'm saying that that's a
style of climbing that you know you can
practice and you can prepare for but no
matter how strong you are it doesn't
make it feel any easier you know it's
like so it's a it's a tough thing like
it's a tough Style the free solo because
no matter you know there's it always
feels a little little on edge you're
like what if my foot slips yeah cuz I
mean what's the term you use blow if
your foot blows out yeah if you blow
that sometimes happens right yeah I mean
you know yeah it happens if you wait it
wrong like You' like to think that
there's a degree of control to it where
like you only blow your foot if you're
inattentive in how you place it or if
your shoes are old or if the friction is
bad or if you know they're with a a lot
of freaking variables and so then you're
sort of like well you know but it feels
random because you're like Oh I thought
it was good my foot blew you're like oh
oops well I must have placed it poorly
or something but you know it doesn't
help if you're
dead
no and then so so you get done with this
and again this is just like your word
you're like you told your buddy like hey
I I I free sold half by the way
yesterday or whatever and then he posts
it somewhere on the interwebs and then
people kind of catch what you're doing
yeah I kind of forget how all this stuff
played out cuz I mean so that was in
2008 which feels like a long time ago
now and that was like pre-social I
didn't have a smartphone yet there was
no easy way to disseminate information
around climbing like that and so you
know I did it my friends knew about it
at some point you know like obviously
told a few people like the I'd climbed
the wall with a partner two days before
with a rope to practice it to you know
see if it was doable and so um so he
knew that I was you know at least toying
with the idea I mean he you know he was
kind of like oh why are we going up here
to practice like obviously he kind of
had a sense of it and so I texted him
when I was done just so you wouldn't be
worried and um you know texted like the
people I was climbing with the next day
to be like okay let's go do you know
whatever um and I don't really know how
it spread from there but then but then
the next year we filmed the movie alone
on the wall which is what you saw in
film festivals and things that toured
with real Rock and and it went on the
the BAM Mountain film tour thing so it
kind of toured internationally and so I
feel like the real you know the half
doome free solo sort of became a big
thing sort of a year and a half later
you already over it yeah by then I'd
already done a bunch of other solos a
bunch of you know been on a couple
Expeditions yeah it like ancient history
by
then dang and then you had to go back
and reenact it yeah yeah but that's fine
because that was just like two days of
two days of work on half
basically look like I said it would make
me mad I'm getting mad for you right now
and apparently it doesn't make you mad
at all like I'm no well can you imagine
a better place to work you know I'm sort
of like oh I'm going up with three of my
good buddies to go camp at one of the
most beautiful places in the world and
this is what I do for a job you're like
this is awesome you know just and and
then the part and well so this is the
thing that I think people don't don't
totally get and is a lot of these films
like alone on the wall when you're like
that's such crazy free soing what you're
seeing is the safest and most secure
stuff on the whole route like you're not
seeing any of the stuff where I actually
think I could fall you're seeing the
stuff that you know I feel totally
comfortable doing on command in weird
weather you know like just whatever when
the guy tells you that it's time to go
you're like okay I can go so whatever
you're seeing is like the chill stuff so
just imagine the not chill stuff in the
book talk about the fact that that the
move that I just read you're like you
you didn't do that again you didn't
reenact that one r that pitch you're
like hell no yeah hell no hell no or if
I was going to I mean I'm sure I could
do that again if I had to but if I went
up there again I would make some major
marks with chalk all over be like Left
Foot Right Foot left foot and like be
positive of like this is exactly how I
do it every time and that's a big part
of the difference in my process between
the the half experience and and then
later fre selling all cap CU like that
passage you read in the intro with the
boulder prom on El Cap that was
perfectly executed where I knew exactly
what to do so I was sort of able to go
into autopilot and just do it whereas on
half you're up there all self-conscious
the whole time being like is this the
right way am I is this the right foot
should I try a different foot but that
feels even worse I should try and even
different you know it's like you're just
doing different stuff and it's like
you're panicking yeah well even when
you're climbing half to I didn't read
this part but you like got a little lost
and turned around on the route itself
which is a little crazy yeah it's
because I had int to go one way and then
I got up there and I just wasn't feeling
that great and I was sort of like oh I
knew that there existed an easier way
that bypassed one of the the cruxes in
the middle of the wall but I'd never
actually gone the easier way but I was
like I'll figure it out and then it
turns out I I totally overshot the easy
way and and did a bunch of stuff those
was unfortunate but that that was a
whole different experience because then
you think you're just lost in the middle
of this 2000 foot wall and you're like
holy [__] you know like you're seeing no
signs of human passage there like bushes
in the cracks and you're kind of like
you know am I like totally lost
appearance yeah but eventually I found
my way back to the route and eventually
if you you could sit you mentioned the
book like well I could sit here and wait
till some more climbers and yell at them
and like get some help if I had to and
and then it's the way you described
getting helicopter rescued it seemed
like you would rather die that's that's
the way you didn't say that in the book
but it seemed like you would rather die
the deepest of shames yeah that' be no I
mean that's the interesting thing with
free soling and eity in particular
because e is quite popular I mean
they're tourists they're climbers they
they're folks around and so you could
always yell for help you could always
just sit down on a little ledge um and
that's the thing with free soing is that
if you slip and fall you're going to die
for sure but if you just suddenly had a
change of heart and you're like you know
what I'm not into this like I can't do
it or something you could find a little
stance here or there you know like uh
the slab pitch that I'm describing on
half do it starts off of this little Le
ledge feature sort of half the size of
this table let's say so you could just
go sit on that little ledge and just sit
there carefully for like a day or two
and wait for somebody to get you and and
in the grand scheme of survival
situations like you you'd be fine you
know you'd shiver through the night and
in a day or two someone would collect
you and it'd be better than dying yeah
it'd be it'd be deeply embarrassing and
and sort of a you know it'd be a hard
thing to overcome confidence wise but
but you'd be alive and they'd be fine
yeah and then when you've got this
Carabiner that you can kind of grab on
to and no one's really watching and it's
like you're either going to die or make
it but I'm gonna hold the line yeah but
then the whole rest of your life you'd
be like yeah I free solid have to mostly
sort of except for that one key move
where I skip the hardest move on the
route you know it'd be weird because you
spent the whole rest of your life being
like oh this thing that I did that I'm
really proud of almost but I'm not that
proud of I'm actually kind of deeply
ashamed of please don't tell anyone you
know it's like it's the alternative also
being you spend the rest of your life
which is about 5 Seconds tumbling yeah I
know it'd be terrible but I know it's
just yeah it's it's a predicament though
because it's something that you're like
this could be you know one of the
crowning achievements of your life so
far or it could be this like deeply
embarrassing thing that you don't want
to talk to anybody about you're sort of
like oh I got an over my head and then
then it all went sideways kind of like I
don't
know uh what about El Sendero
luminoso you like that Echo Charles how
was that well you know not
bad this one again now this one looks
like little tiny freaking holdes this
isn't much much crack activity is it no
no but it's um horrifying man well an
important distinction is that cero is uh
is limestone so it's a different type of
rock so it's um it's like these porous
solution pockets it's all these little
holes and so actually it's way more
featured than theity everything we've
talked about so actually not everything
so several of the things we've talked
about so far have being on granite so
it's basically like Smooth blank faces
with cracks on them through them um and
then Moonlight buts is sandstone but
that's also just a pure crack cero is
just a whole different thing cuz
limestone is like a different type of
rock it's porous it has like different
types of little nooks and crannies in it
and so I don't know I mean CER though is
actually harder than any of the other
ones um that we've been talking about
technically and it's just kind of bigger
and harder I mean cero represented a
whole different step like it was and
also it was many years later and I was a
much better climber this is now like
2014 yeah yeah I saw cindera though as
part of the leadup to free selling Al
cap like there were there were three
routs basically like I I wanted to Sol
LC cap uh as soon as I so it half them
like in 2008 LC cap was the obvious next
thing I was like I should do that cuz
it's the next big but it just was too
hard and too daunting and like too too
far beyond and so I kind of had three
other hard walls that uh that I wanted
to do leading up to cap and cero was one
of them and then the other two uh Were
Never filmed or got photos or anything
they're just these two random roots that
you haven't heard of but they're also
one of them I did with almost no prep
because I ran out of freaking propane in
my van and the drive up into the
mountains to get to the place was so
heinous and windy that I was like
there's no way I'm going to drive back
to town to get more propane and then
drive back up here I was like I'm just
going to not eat dinner and then climb
it tomorrow and then leave for good cuz
I was like I don't want to drive there
where was that that's that's in the
needles it's uh this place in the high
sea area um out between Fresno and
Bakersfield just kind of like in the
middle of nowhere it's like these really
nice Granite spes that are like tucked
away in the mountains and it was really
hard yeah it's really hard it's um it's
like same as any of the other ones yeah
it's hard it's like a 10 or 12 pitch 12b
but it's really really technical Granite
did they film um luminos or live or did
you reenact no so they I think there
were people there when I did it but this
was like pre- doumentary film making I
think the filmmakers were uncomfortable
everybody was kind of like let's just
let it you do your thing and so I
actually sold that with a little day bag
on because I needed food and water and I
needed my shoes so I could hike down off
the Su of the mountain Cinder luminoso
climbs this sort of tower feature and so
normally you climb it and then you repel
the Tower with two ropes but if you
don't have a rope then uh I scrambled
back to the to the wall of the mountain
behind it and then continued on to the
summit of that mountain so another like
I don't know 500 feet or 1,000 ft or
something of like kind of [__]
jungle climbing to get to the top of the
mountain and then you can hike down the
other side of the mountain on like a
normal tour Trail but so my free solar
experience was like little unusual and
they have a little bag on I've got food
and water I've got supplies you know cuz
climbing with a backpack you know it
only it's like what 2 or 3 lbs or
something of extra weight which
represents almost nothing in the grand
scheme of you know as a percentage of
mass and so but obviously it looks way
worse in film and so they didn't want to
shoot like a long shot of me up there
with my little day bag like going going
to school you know so then later when we
went back and filmed on it you're just
up there in your T-shirt looking like a
hero like oh what a great what a great
shot you're like yeah it looks way
better everybody's happy it's like makes
a great
film it's freaking py go to look at yeah
yeah that one especially the things like
so filming on cero I don't think I I
didn't do the Crux again I didn't do a
couple of things but the sections that I
did do are still 512 they're still like
sort of elite rock climbing and they
look I mean they look yeah like the
footage still looks insane it looks
heinous yeah and there's like a massive
wind like it's super windy which also
you know I'm just already uncomfortable
and then there's this super strong wind
blowing and I'm like this does not look
cool to me I mean it looks awesome to me
but it looks horrifying yeah yeah yeah
but that's I mean that's the nature of
filming in mountains you know sometimes
it's cold sometimes it's windy it's just
like you're in the mountains yeah and
and and so you said as soon as you
climbed half do you you knew that ELC
cap was G to be somewhere in the future
yeah elap was always kind of a life
dream for sure I mean it's just I mean
you've seen it it's have you seen it
what El Cap you've been to e no I never
been there but I've seen it on you guys
see
it
yeah when you see it in real life I mean
it's just so it's so Mega it's so it's
inspiring it's Grand it's it's vast it's
like it's everything you're just like
wow and so you know I was spending maybe
three months a year in e in my van and
you know it's like your whole life
revolves around elcap basically it's
like you drive past every day you look
at it you're like that's so epic so yeah
I mean it was always the the big
goal is there I mean also like at some
point um a journalist had written an
outside magazine like a a speculative
piece like the race to freeing all cap I
mean it was like an obvious challenge
for climbing who who was in the race
well me and I mean the guy that wrote
the article was sort of speculating
between me and Dean Potter I don't know
if you remember him but he's not
deceased but he was also a very talented
free soloist and he uh was Bas jumping a
lot and had kind of you know I sort of
fondly called him the dark wizard
because he had a lot of sort of dark
arts like you know base jumping and and
he was just sort of a dark Broody Soul
yeah for sure but but um but he was
certainly capable of of something like
that you know he maybe he was never
quite there but he certainly I mean I
know he thought about it like he was he
was interested for sure so the race was
you two yeah or I mean or who knows who
else because I mean anybody that has
free sold it a little on climing has at
least thought about it you know as like
a magical like wouldn't that be crazy
you know it's but it's an obvious
possibility when you are thinking about
doing this um what's like the driving
thing that's making you want to do this
that' be so cool I I mean you know it's
it's just the obvious challenge I mean
it's hard to describe how important yed
is to climbing history and climbing
culture and you know climbing mythology
and then elcap is sort of central to
that and there's been so much climbing
history written on the walls of elcap
like I mean just the first Asen ofal cap
was groundbreaking at the time as the
the most difficult biggest big wall in
the world and then
you know I guess what which was which
was a to like a it's a different it's a
totally different thing what they did
back then yeah yeah totally different
thing it took him 18 months of effort
and you know 40 days on the wall and
drilling all these bolts it's like a
whole process it's almost it was almost
like a construction project you know in
a way you're just like literally
drilling holes into the wall and but but
crazy because at that point ropes didn't
hold Falls so I mean that's a big uh
that's a big thing I mean they had ropes
and the ropes would help but if you took
a big fall there's like a legitimate
chance the Rope would break nowadays
that's not a thing nowadays A climbing
rope uh you know unless something crazy
happens like you could fall the whole
length of the rope and it's totally fine
and and the Rope absorbs in a force that
you won't even be hurt you'll just kind
of be like oh boingy you know like a
little bouncy it's like totally chill
but back then sort of like oh you don't
even have a real harness the rope's not
going to catch a fall it's all pretty uh
it's pretty adventurous up there but but
yeah
so you know there's been so much
climbing history written on Al cap from
the first Ascent to the the first in a
day Ascent to the first free ascent you
know to like all these big milestones in
in climbing have occurred on El Cap and
so it makes sense that as a you know mid
20s like hungry young man like looking
to do something cool you're like oh
that's that's the place to do
it so you started thinking about that in
2008 and now 2009 2010 2012 or 14 you
know you're doing these other things and
you're just progressively getting better
can you feel yourself getting better are
you getting stronger are you just
getting more technical no it's so slow I
mean I'm sure I don't know I assume that
you've been the same with all the sports
and things that you do is like you
improve so slowly that you never really
realize how much better you've gotten
you're just kind of like I mean in
climbing you just basically feel like
you suck every day because climbing is
mostly failing you know you're always
trying things that are just past your
limit and you're always failing and so
every day you mostly fail and then every
once in a while you have experiences of
great success where you're like oh I did
a thing that was hard for me like I'm
proud of myself but but mostly you just
it's just the grind you know you just go
climb and you get worked and you feel
tired and you know yeah it's weird in in
Jiu-Jitsu in particular you like you're
getting so much better but you don't
know it like my me right now would kill
me six months ago or maybe a year ago
cuz and when you get better you don't
improve quite as much as used in the
beginning but but you definitely are
improving over time and if you ever have
someone that like stopped training and
you keep training like they're just in a
totally different world you can
annihilate them totally
so as you're climbing and as you're
improving but you can't really perceive
that you're improving at what point do
you start to contemplate like for real
oh this is on the map yeah it's yeah
it's a good question so I mean I think
that I could break it down is from so
2008 I so a half do and I'm like I'm
going to Sol cap next and so starting in
2009 it was kind of like this is the
year then I got there and I was like
this is not the year it's like totally
insane it looks you know I was like
makes you want to poop when you think
about it you're sort of like oh jeez
like there's no chance I'm sing that
this year
and then I kept kind of hoping that it
would just feel easy at some point that
you know I kept hoping that I would
improve enough that I would look up at
the wall and think that looks easy like
I can just do that and you know so the
years Roll by and I am doing harder
things and I'm getting better and I'm
going on Expedition you know I'm doing
all these other things that I'm proud of
in climbing but every year you look up
at o capab and still just think that
looks totally impossible and so starting
in basically in
2015 I realized that it was never going
to look easy you know I was like no
matter how good I get it well I realized
two things one I realized that I was
never going to get good enough that it
was just going to look easy because I
kept kind of thinking that I might just
hit certain grades and climbing like
reach certain difficulty levels where
like if I could climb that grade then it
would look easy MH and I was like that's
just one I'm never going to hit these
grades two even if I did it's not going
to look easy it's still all cap it's
still it'd still be insane and so I
realized that if I wanted to do it I
would have to just put the work
specifically into the climb itself and
like basically do all the prep work as
if I was going to even though I wasn't
sure if I could or not you know sort of
act as if I was going to with the
uncertainty there of knowing that like
maybe I can't but I'll at least do all
the prep work and find out and that
started in
2015 yeah and sort of by happy
coincidence um Jimmy chin and chai
vasarelli the the co-directors of free
solo approached me that same year um
about doing a feature film project uh
they didn't know anything about o cap
and you know I kept my cards very close
to the chest on that stuff CU it's all
sort of I it's it's weird like you don't
really talk to friends about this stuff
but umit wait wait why don't you talk to
your friends about this stuff because
everybody tells you you shouldn't do it
and and it makes everybody deeply
uncomfortable and nobody really wants to
know about it ahead of time like you
don't want to put that burden on
somebody like oh I'm going to go do this
thing I might die tomorrow you know it's
like it's better for they feel bad
because they didn't oh I should have
said something I should have told them
this like I thought he look sketchy I
should have said something and you're
like no it's not on you you know God I
feel that way about like fights like
I've had friends that have done mixed
martial arts fights or where I've I've
been like man I shouldn't have let them
go I should have said something so yeah
if they died yeah you'd be like oh jeez
yeah it's just it's just better not to
but then but then the other thing about
it is that if you tell your buddy like
I'm going to do this thing tomorrow and
then you hike up there and you're like
you know actually it's kind of cold and
I just don't feel it today you know like
for whatever reason I don't want to do
it but then you're like oh but I don't
want to have to go back and then tell my
buddy that I bailed because then he's
going to think I'm light duty even
though your buddy doesn't want you to
anyway but you know what I mean it
starts adding all this psychology to it
that you just don't need it's better
just to feel like it's totally on you
you go up if you're not feeling it you
walk back there's like no second
guessing the psychology of that yeah
that that is that's kind of crazy you
know what's interesting I I've talked
about the psychology of um in Special
Operations right so like my last
deployment to Iraq the Special
Operations guys which is me my seals we
kind of got to choose what missions we
were going to do like oh oh there's a
mission oh there's a bad guy or there's
an area we want to go to my it's my
decision I'm literally saying okay we
will go do
this and the burden that you have from
that is like oh someone gets hurt or
someone gets killed that was 100% was
your decision the conventional forces
often times they're getting told like
hey you're going to go do this and so
when that leader gets told hey you're
going to go do this they're going do it
if someone gets hurt or killed they were
just kind of executing and there's
there's like a different different
psycholog that you have when you're
depending on what situation you're in
and yeah I could see that the thing like
this here you're you're choosing to do
it you don't want to have the burden of
any
other mindset or any other pressure of
like well you know Fred's really going
to think I'm I'm weak if I don't do this
today or whatever they got all even they
all got set up for me to do this and
then I didn't do it well that's the hard
thing with filming is because if there's
a whole crew you know like with filming
free solo there'd be you know six or
eight people involved in like getting up
on the wall getting to the summit
repelling into position and if you get
up and you're like you know I just
didn't sleep that well and I don't
really feel it today but you know that
eight of your buddies set their alarm
for 3:30 so they could hike to the
summit of a mountain and repel in you're
kind of like man I'm doing a big
disservice to the team if I don't show
up and perform so then you're sort of
like but then but then you don't want to
force it either because if it's not your
day it's not your day and you and you
can't force that yeah it's weird in free
solo you can see that they're all not
they're Notting to apply any of that
pressure to you whatsoever yeah gosh
yeah cuz they're I mean they're in a
super tough spot because like they don't
want to pressure me there's this whole
weird mirror mirroring effect where with
filming where if you're doing something
difficult and there's a film guy near
you filming it like you know that
they're uncomfortable because you know I
mean they're a climber as well they're
watching something that they know is
hard and they're like holy [__] this is
kind of intense and so you want to make
it look as effortless as possible like
you want to look in control because you
don't want to freak out your buddy but
then you don't want to climb differently
because you're like trying to look
smooth and in control and so it's this
whole back and forth mirror where you're
like I want to look good so I don't
scare them because I know they're scared
but then you know it's it's all bad
basically but that's why um in the in
that that passage that you read um at
the beginning when I do the boulder
problem when I mentioned that their
cameras on the wall those were both
remote operated cameras that they had
sort of rigged up as a as a special
system so that I wouldn't have to deal
with having an operator on the wall
there yeah yeah cuz you're trying to
mirror for them that you're calm and
they're trying to do the same thing CU
they don't want to look like oh my God
yeah because if I look over and I see my
buddy crying I'd be like oh [__] today
is not my day like Mikey Who's down in
the valley who's filming he's like
turning away he's just like can't look
at the camera that that would probably
make you super uncomfortable if you
could have seen that super sketch I've
done I've done a lot with Mikey because
Mikey has been uh Jimmy Chin's photo
assistant for a bunch of different
things he's got a poker face for when
it's up close actually well no so I've
done a couple shoes with Mikey where he
was holding the lights for Jimmy and uh
and he literally just was looking away
the entire time he would hold the light
in the correct position all the settings
are correct but he just like wouldn't
watch the shoot at all he's like I don't
need to see this he be like it's pretty
funny dang he just but he's he's a he's
an elite climber himself and and I've
also been on Expeditions with him and
stuff like notably we were together on
this trip in Greenland a year and a half
ago which was also like a TV Expedition
thing and and um and so he's he's a
hardcore climber that like knows how all
this stuff works but basically when he's
working you know when he's filming he's
just like I don't need to see it like
unless I need to watch I'm not going to
dang yeah that's how he deals with it
yeah yeah I remember doing this this uh
this crack uh for um Jimmy chin shot
this this feature for for National
Geographic the magazine that that I was
on the cover of actually there's a photo
from uh from half but so Mikey was like
holding the lights for all these
different photos and he just like didn't
just like covered his eyes for the whole
shoot it's like totally
crazy yeah I think I think when you were
on Joe Rogan you were talking about you
know he's like how do you do this how do
you do this and and you're were like it
for me it feels like I'm walking down
the sidewalk that's what you said like
something along those lines some things
it's not always quite that solid but but
a Spire two anyway yeah and I was like I
try to put that in perspective CU you
know we all have little skill sets that
we have what we're good at and it seems
really to do that thing and yet at the
same time even the things that you're
good at sometimes you mess up so Mikey's
probably thinking could be could it be
the time though you rarely mess up the
thing you're good at on the day that
you're not supposed to mess up MH you
know I mean like I think there is a a
distinction like when you're on you're
really on I know yeah and you've you've
likely subconsciously or consciously
gotten to a point in your life where you
know how to be on and this I need to be
on right now cuz again with Fighters
there's some Fighters
that they they look great in practice
and they do great in practice and game
time they they don't bring it they mess
up they make mistakes they get psyched
out and there's some people that they're
the opposite like they do okay in
training and they're like man I don't
know if's how they bring their aame and
and crush and yeah you you probably have
done enough things where you're like oh
yeah I need to do this right and also
being able to recognize I'm not
I can't do this right now now's not the
day now's not the time I need to stop I
think that's one of the interesting
things that differentiates climbing from
a lot of other sports is that you know
with fighting you have to show up on the
day of the fight and you have to perform
at your best but with climbing you show
up and you're just like today's not my
day you come back the next week or you
come back the next day or you know you
basically just you get to choose your
timing and I I always think about that
with Ball Sports yeah you know when
you're like it's it's Sunday I have to
play you're kind of like what if I don't
want to play on Su what if I want to
play on Tuesday you know it's like what
if my KNE kind ofy and I want to chill
for another day like with climbing you
can always choose your best day and then
you can really make your days count yeah
the worst is the Olympics oh dude it's
been four years eight years or whatever
preparation and now you like I got a
stomach ache on game day you're leg
gymnast or whatever and you got to go
out there and do the best no four years
of of periodized training where you've
been like doing some crazy cycle up and
down for four years and you're like this
is my Peak and you're like yeah but
actually I I think I ate something weird
you know my stomach kind of hurts yeah
it's like that's crazy to me I mean
climbing is is so chill by that you know
by that comparison but the stakes
obviously are like you have to choose
your day because you could die yeah I
wonder if you've become like hyper
sensitive to how you feel just through
whereas like a a wrestler or a gymnast
has just been like no it doesn't matter
how I feel I just need to go perform
whereas you're like H you know what
today's you you probably could rate each
of your days and subconsciously like yep
today I'm feeling good and it's when
when you watch the movies and when you
write about it in the book you're like
you can you you know when you're feeling
good yeah actually I wonder about that
because uh you know I've never done any
other sport well enough to really know
but I've noticed like with climbing
training like actually so during the
free solo movie tour um like you know
the film came out I was doing this crazy
you know six-month like press to her
like non-stop events and at the time I
had a pretty structured training plan um
and I I was like training in the gym and
and it was like the only thing that kept
me saying through the whole six months
of like in just crazy Hollywood stuff
but I noticed that when you know with
non-stop travel like different different
climbing jamm and a different city every
day sort of thing and my climbing
performance was pretty erratic depending
on sleep and and whatever but when I
would do the extra things like weighted
pull-ups and like weight sort of things
my numbers are pretty consistently good
that you know no matter how tired you
are you can still just like lift a heavy
ass weight maybe not like absolute Peak
Performance but in general you can kind
of hit your gym numbers but my climbing
performance was all over the place
because uh and as I found out from the
the coach I was working with I think it
has more to do with the let's see can I
can I repeat it correctly basically just
that there's a there's a coordination
element to it like uh like you know
firing your muscles at the right time
like because climbing is such a
complicated movement it's not just like
flex your muscles it's like so many
different muscles working in concert and
like basically it's really complicated
the more tired you are like that stuff
just doesn't doesn't fire the same way
and so as a climber all that to say that
I think as a climber you are very
attuned to like how your body feels and
as a climber when you get injuries
they're all on your fingers and like
little tiny where you're like oh I feel
a tiny tiny little tweak in my finger
and it's like you look at the NFL or
something and people have like a broken
femur and they're like getting taped up
and going back in yeah they're taking
like six bikins and getting a bunch of
tape and they're like finishing the game
and you're like holy [__] you know
because as a climber you're like I think
my one knuckle is like a little swollen
I just can't quite hold that hold quite
right you're like I got to take a rest
week you know it's like and it makes you
feel super light duty compared to other
sports because like you know people are
training through like the craziest
things but it just it just doesn't work
that way you just can't especially not
when your freaking life's at stake and
and you're not if you're not free
soloing you're probably not as I mean
assume not as concerned like if you're
just going to do a normal rock climb and
you're not feeling that great you're
like okay I get my Knuckles a little
sore but I'll power through it it's no
big deal yeah though actually even that
you often don't power through because
your your fingers are so delicate
basically like basically the tools of
the trade are so delicate it'd be like a
pist you know like if they start to feel
like some pain in their fingers they're
like oo I should probably ease off that
because I just won't be able to do my
thing if like you know basically any
kind of pain in tendons ligaments in
your arms or fingers you're pretty
pretty mindful of because if they get
out of control like you're kind of hos
for a while like if if you injure a
finger you're like out for a while I'm
going to show you later some picture of
some Jiu-Jitsu people's hands and
fingers oh all broken and like Twisted
because especially people that compete
with the uniform on with the ghee on the
jiujitsu G everything is grabbing and
squeezing and like it's guy hands look
so gnarly the Meow brothers you ever
seen their their hands like it's famous
pictures of just hands that every
knuckle is like swollen it's it's it's
it's crazy but they their life doesn't
depend on being able to hang on they'll
make adjust
though they do get all messed up don't
they it's like life doesn't depend on
but they're getting punch in the face or
something aren't they yeah in well in in
when you get into mixed martial arts
yeah um in Jiu-Jitsu there's no punching
there's just like choking and breaking
arms and stuff oh yeah yeah yeah just a
broken arm show it's a little more
mellow so this is all that that actually
though so that's another thing that I
think differentiates climbing from a lot
of these other sports is that with
climbing it's like yes the stakes are
very high that you could die I mean with
free soing you could die but you know
I've gone I've been a climber for 28
years and I've had like almost no
injuries and I feel like a lot of these
other sports you know it's like you're
getting kind of messed up all the time I
think about that with outdoor sport it's
like mountain biking where it's like if
you're a serious mountain biker like
you're breaking a collar bone like every
couple years you know it's like like
you're getting injured all the time yeah
and and if you're a professional
mountain biker like you're having a
major surgery like every four years for
sure biking mountain biking is when I
watch Mountain baking I'm I'm just
uncomfortable crazy so but so with
climbing it's like you're not going to
have any of those injuries your whole
career but you're always facing that
risk of death and to me I kind of prefer
it that way where it's like yeah the
consequences are there you have to stay
attentive like you could die but at
least you're not freaking getting
shoulder surgery every couple years and
like you know like man I don't know I
think it's a nice way to live dude those
mountain bikers go after it too like the
downhill mountain bikers that are just
bombing and when they and when you wipe
out with a bike I mean that just adds
this whole freaking apparatus
[Music]
if you and you were rock climbing and
even if you were roped up but you had
you wereing a bicycle with you just you
have a b TI to you swinging
past awful it's like when you fall ice
climbing and you have like pointy things
on every you know you have crampons on
you have ice tools you have like all
these pointy things swinging around and
you're like oh my God trying to stay
clear of everything yeah the ice
climbing you know they sell ski Poes and
they have like little ice climbing yeah
Whip It yeah the little point on the and
you're like what if I follow because
when you follow skiing you're just it's
just a disaster right it just
everything's everywhere well those are
for a very specific application like
extreme steep skiing where you have to
self rest and stuff but no for the
average person on the slope they should
not have a freaking ice to at the end of
their ski
pole noted yeah yeah no if you're just
out at the resort you should not have a
spike on the end of your ski po it's
like some poor snowboarder hits you at
full speed
dies goes through their
helmet well everything that we're
talking about though it it actually did
it plays out in free solo because you're
all what was it 2017 you're all in the
in the runup going through all the
drills doing all the prep and you go you
go you go and you start the climb and
you get what 500t up and you you're not
feeling it and you walk away yeah
actually so it's funny you read that
excerpt from from halone because I
actually did exactly what we were
describing on halone I got yeah 500 ft
up basically to the free blast labs to
this like blank section of rock and and
there are bolts in the Rock so that
people climbing with ropes can clip the
rope in and so I got up there and there
no hand holds and I was like I'm not
feeling it and started just grabbing the
bolts and so you're still climbing
without a rope you know you're still
clet up yeah still 500 ft up it's like
if you fall you're still going to die
but by holding the bolts it makes the
difficulty much much easier cuz you
suddenly have things to hold that keep
you balanced and it's like way more
chill and so you know I cheated by using
the bolts got across the slab and then
cheated a bit further and then uh and
then climbed another 400 feet of easy
terrain to get up to this big ledge
system where there fixed lines that go
back down to the ground from there and
that's like a normal aspect like that's
part of El Cap that everybody uses that
all climbers use and so yeah it's funny
it's not like I climb 500 feet and I was
like cool I want to go down you know I
still had to go up another another 500
ft to get to the weight that you can get
down um but I just like chea way I was
thinking cheting on half it's just like
a way to escape the wall free blast the
way it looks it's basically a few
hundred feet of what we were talking
about earlier where you just don't get
the full security yeah yeah it's just
totally blank I mean so the Crux moves
the free blast lab like the hardest
section um there actually no handholds
at all and it's just this three foot
move sequence where you just you're just
standing on your big toes and if your
foot slips you're going to die but you
know it's low angle so it's like it's
less than vertical and it's like just
tip toeing across the wall which is
balanc in your big toes it's like but so
that and that's why I bailed because I'd
sprained my ankle earlier that season um
in a in a climbing fall and my foot had
been kind of swollen and I was kind of
swollen in the shoe and and also that
time of year it was early November it's
just really cold out um and and dark and
you're required to climb that early
because you're trying to get to some of
the upper stuff before it goes into the
sun U whereas in the springtime because
the sun is higher in the sky it Shades
it the wall Shades itself longer and so
you have better conditions for for a
longer amount of time but in the fall
because the sun is so low like as soon
as the sunrises you're just baking so it
means you have to start Way Before
Sunrise so anyway it's like basically
conditions felt a little bit stacked
against me and I couldn't feel my feet
and it was kind of chilly and then and
then suddenly you have to trust your
life to this big toe and you're like I
can't feel my big toe and it's freaking
dark and it's scary you're like no at
this like this is not this is not my
thing at the time though it was very
disappointing I felt like a total
failure you know you're just like oh the
whole team is up here and I let them
down I really want to do this thing
though it's funny because now in
retrospect I'm glad I bailed because
then I went home and I did a bunch of pt
on my ankle trained All Season came back
the next uh spring spent two more months
working specifically on the route and
then when I finally did it felt like a
total boss and it was great you know so
like you know it's the classic thing
where where what feels like a failure at
the moment you know in in hindsight
you're like oh it only took me six more
months of effort and it up me a much
better experience in the long run so I'm
kind of like you know what's what's 6
months of effort when compared to like
compared to like the thing you're going
to be most proud of your whole life
probably and the the confidence level
after you work an extra six months is
just going to totally it's so much high
and actually and it was good for me and
the film crew to have a bit of a dry run
where because actually that was the
first time and this sounds stupid but
just hiking up to the Basel cap with no
rope is a bit of a big mental step and
so just having done it once before
you're like okay well at least I
remember what it's like to walk up to
the wall and just tie put on my shoes
tie my shoes and start climbing because
it's really different than the normal
routine which is laying out the Rope
getting all your gear ready like talking
to your partner you know it's like
normally there's a whole process before
you start climbing all cap and when you
go there to free solo you're like oh
this this feels different you know it's
like feels a little
heavier the you use the term
autopilot when when you're talking about
some of those really hard moves and even
when you're talking about just like
you'll get into mode where you're just
autopilot you just know what you're
doing and you do it is that not is that
what you're striving for during training
uh not so much during training that's
what I aspire to during performance for
sure I mean though actually now that you
mention I'm like maybe it would be
better if I was a little more like that
in training but um but it's for me it's
really hard to access that 100% effort
like you know that's that's like Flow
State that's like outof body experiences
whatever you want to call it you know
and and I think that's true across all
kinds of sort of elite Sports
Performance but I think it's pretty hard
to tap into that 100% like I'm giving it
everything I have and I mean it's
probably possible for me to do that
while training on the board or something
you know like I have a little gym in my
garage and I train but man it's hard to
care that much like when you're in the
garage you know your friends are there
you're listen to music you're you know
it's all pretty chill and like you try
your hardest but on sort of a
superficial level of like oh I'm trying
hard you're not like trying the hardest
you've ever tried in your life it's it's
funny when people are going to compete
in Jiu-Jitsu and they've never competed
before they're like oh what should I get
ready for I'm like get ready for someone
to be going harder than anyone has ever
gone at you before and for you to be
using muscles in a way that you've never
used them before so what you're saying
is actually 100% right you get into
competition and people are going
completely insane psycho and we're you
know if you and I are training and like
you start to get a position on me oh
cool I'll abandon that and go to
something else no if we're in a match
like I am never going to abandon
anything until you break me it's such a
different yeah it's a death match and
and so it is very hard to push someone
that hard in training in fact for and
and you probably shouldn't because you
get injured right you know it's like the
stakes are too high that way for sure
cuz like that's the thing is you don't
really want to train with that kind of
intensity because you know I I know that
I mean you'll burn out you'll get
injured it's just it's just a lot like
you can't like not every game can be
Super Bowl you know or whatever whatever
Sports metaphor you want but are are you
going
autopilot like when it's like okay this
is kind of an easy area and I'm just
going to kind of autopilot through this
I don't have to think about it too much
and then are there areas where you're
like I need to pay attention to what I'm
doing right now no okay so actually
that's a that's an interesting question
in some ways it's almost like two
different autopilots because yeah you're
right that on the easy terrain there is
you know I go into autopilot but that's
more like a Mindless climbing cuz on
easy Terrain and and El Cap the freeo of
ELC cap kind of breaks down as like a
third easy a third like medium and a
third like hard Cutting Edge sort of and
so the easy terrain you know you can
like think about your buddies you can
think about what you're having for lunch
you like look at the weather you look at
the birds it's like it's it's lovely and
you can just kind of trust your body to
just climb because it's quite easy and
then the moderate train you can do a lot
of that mindlessly as well but typically
on the moderate pitches there'll be at
least some sections where you have to
like pay attention but then on the
hardest stuff I sort of aspire to a
different kind of autopilot where it's
not like Mindless climbing it's more
like perfect thoughtless climbing you
know what I mean I don't know it's it's
a hard distinction to make but but
that's kind of the good autopilot where
you're performing perfectly but you're
just not distracted by anything else
yeah yeah the idea of thinking about
when you're walking down the stairs or
up the stairs I think I think is a you
that used that example Echo Charles like
if you you can walk up down the stairs
like a 100 times but if you think about
while you're walking up the stairs
you're more apt to like trip up yourself
fall down or it happens to people when
they're speaking where they're trying to
speak in a certain way so they're
thinking about what they're saying and
it jams them up and they're stuttering
and making mistakes and all that whereas
you know what you're going to say you've
done this a bunch of times you need to
not think about it and just do it I mean
this again any sports like that if
you're on the on the free throw line in
basketball with the state championship
on the line you don't want to think
about the mechanics of your free throw
that's not the time to be like okay yeah
straight back and bent arms and here you
know it's like you just want to do the
thing that you're there to do exactly
and that's the autopilot that yeah
that's the good autopilot when you just
do what you know how to do you do
whatever you've done in practice a
million times and you don't think about
it just do it monkey mind yeah actually
I think about it a lot for um I thought
that a good analogy for for the climbing
for like the the boulder problem let's
say on on NOC cap um I compare it to
gymnastics because I think that a
gymnastics routine it's like you
practice through routine over and over
and over but then once you're doing the
routine I mean I don't know gymnastics
at all but I imagine that Elite gymnasts
aren't thinking about their routine at
all when they're doing it because it's
such complicated movement and so fast
that they're just executing and then
afterward they can sort of replay it and
think like oh I should have done
something differently or not but while
they do it I I presume that they're just
doing it you know they're not they're
not self-conscious about it at all
they're just performing and I would
venture to Guess that if they start
thinking about they're the
routine freaking land on their face it's
going to be a problem yeah for sure yeah
like halfway through your back
handspring or whatever you can't be like
am I tucked right like no you just you
just do
it the uh I had a a thing so there in
the military there's something called
noo
criteria no go Criterion were not going
so oh we were expected that we would
have aircraft to support our movement to
the Target we don't have the aircraft
that's no go criteria we're not going
totally we don't have whatever resupply
that we expecting so therefore we're not
going or it's like 50 mph winds and we
just can't jump in or do whatever yeah
so we have no go criteria so I used to
joke around kind of joking but also kind
of serious that for me I had go go
criteria which is we're going right this
was like my attitude like we're
going and that was sort of just to get
over oh there's been a little hiccup Hey
listen guys we're going but then there
was also this thing of hey we didn't get
the aircraft we we got some other Intel
now oh we the the supply resupply that
we expected isn't like things would
start to add up and I felt as if sort of
like the universe was telling me yeah
that this is not your day this is not
the day and I had no problem being like
Oh yeah there's three things that are
going wrong we're not doing this yeah
and I think that it's important to know
that sometimes you got to push and
sometimes you got to pay attention to
what the universe is trying to tell you
about what's happening no I totally
agree otherwise
you want to you never want to be like
dudy you don't want to like give up to
you don't want to give up
prematurely that said there are certain
times where you just shouldn't be doing
the thing you know like yeah it starts
to rain you're like it's not it's not my
day like that's fine that's that's
nature both in reading the book and then
watching I I've watched a bunch of uh
movies with you in it obviously over the
last couple weeks but when you're going
it's real obvious like just the way you
carry yourself when you're going it's
like oh yeah he you could see when
you're getting out of you're like oh
yeah he's going and you can it's pretty
clear that you're amped and hyped and
there's probably not much that would
turn you away from making this happen
yeah I mean it takes I mean yeah for me
personally it's like hard to totally
turn on and then once you're like on and
doing it it's sort of hard to turn back
off too like once you're psyched you're
like okay it's it's go time I'm doing it
and then I mean basically exactly what
you're describing like you know your go
go you're kind of like then it takes a
lot to switch back to noo but I don't
know I mean yeah free soling is just an
interesting and I think it's important
for anyone listening to this who doesn't
climb there's an important distinction
here between free soling and climbing in
general because you know everything
we're talking about with like Elite
Performance and like all this go I mean
this is for free soling the most
cuttingedge things that I've done in my
life but in general for climbing I just
go climb every day or five days a week
you know it's like if it's raining if
it's windy you're like yeah it's fine I
mean if you have a rope you have
protection it's worth climbing in
adverse conditions it's worth sort of
pushing into discomfort just because you
know it's good for you and long term and
or whatever it's just a beautiful day to
go out and do some climbing you know
it's not like all climbing is Extreme
but we're just talking about the most
Cutting Edge free soling yeah there's
definitely if you're just listening to
this and it sounds interesting but you
don't want to die that's go go to the
gym go to a Climbing gym I mean I
started in a Climbing Gym everybody goes
to a Climbing Gym normally climbing is
super chill super safe really fun and
social you hang out with your friends on
a sofa you all Boulder a little bit it's
like it's really quite enjoyable I think
if this is your first introduction
climbing you're getting a very very like
sort of the wrong look at like the most
intense I
apologize this is not like climbing for
me I think of yeah I think of going to
the going to the gym but also even at
yosee cool we would go up with my kids
who would be you know 6 n and whatever
and they'd be scrambling up the rocks
and be roped in and be like it's really
fun and there's little problems to
figure out and they get to learn the
ropes and everything so yeah there's a
whole it's it's fun it's safe there
normally a lot of snacks involved a lot
of chill time it's like it's a pretty
recreational sport really you know I
mean when I started climbing when I was
10 uh my dad would take my sister and me
to The Climbing gym and uh and he wasn't
a climber but they just read about it
opening in the newspaper and they're
like oh this would be cool because I L
climbing on stuff so I thought I'd you
know like the gym and and yeah we would
go for several hours there would be
snacks you know we would take our time
we would top R up some things everyone
have a good time then we go home it's
like total Suburban fun it's like going
to do laser tag or something you know so
I think that when we're talking about
like extreme freeing you know it sort of
belies the fun of climbing and and and
that it I mean even though I've you know
I guess made a career out of doing this
extreme free soing whatever I'm still
going climbing normally what like 300
days a year and then I have one or two
you know extreme high performance days
which I think is probably similar to
most other sports where you spend most
of your year training and practicing and
doing whatever else and then you have
the occasional moments of of hopeful
Excellence you where you try your best
to do the thing that you're trying to do
we definitely hope for excellence when
you're out there but you just never
quite well but I mean I'm sure with
fights and stuff where it's like you
train the whole year and then you have
your one fight where you're like this is
my moment and you like hope that you're
going to do your best but you know but
you find out it's like the one time of
year that you test yourself against your
training the getting to the top of lcap
now you're the I mean like you said this
is the the most iconic
wall and now you just knocked the [__]
out of the
park
uh did you how long did it take for that
to sink
in a little bit I don't know I mean well
you know the crew every my friends were
all psyched I was psyched I mean we were
we were really psyched immediately
though so this is an example of being a
professional so I summoned all cap I was
obviously psyched we did some interviews
and things I actually trained that
afternoon because uh because I was on
this like routine I didn't want to break
through routine it was funny cuz I
summoned it and I felt so good I was
like I can do it again I'm so amped I
Feel Like A Champion and you know and
then I went down and tried to do my
normal afternoon training on the
hangboard and I was objectively very
tired and like didn't perform that well
on the board and it was sort of like
maybe I shouldn't try it again I I am a
little tired you know it's the classic
you're just so psyched you're like I
could do anything and then you actually
start training and you're like I
couldn't do anything right now I'm
pretty tired but how about pizza yeah
exactly no actually um by sheer happy
coincidence the next day or maybe the
day after was uh was Sunday in y they do
a crazy brunch spread at the Yani um
which is like the fancy hotel in in none
of us were staying there but they do
this insane brunch that you can show up
for and I hadn't eaten dessert in like 6
months or something and then we all went
to danani had like you know Nella of
French toast and like we all just did
the all you can eat brunch and just
gorged on like eggs and pancakes and you
know whatever it was like a it was a
perfect sort of decompression like party
after cuz I mean the crew was also
incredibly stressed all the filmers and
we all had been working very hard on it
yeah that must have been one of the
biggest all-time Collective size of
relief yeah totally totally but no so
what I was going to say though is that
this is where being a professional comes
in so I did the climb we all gorged at
the buffet and then I think I spent the
next five days in a row up on ELC cap
filming so I mean it was like did the
climb was like this is a life
achievement and then we spent five more
days up there like shooting close-ups of
things shooting like moving ropes around
like shooting you know cuz if you watch
it like the little hand holds exactly
all the little hand holes that get cut
in like the little Foo holes the
close-ups of things even some of the
soing like we shot some of the still
photos um cuz there was a article on
National Geographic magazine they shot
like a VR like a 360 thing you know just
like things that accompanied the film
basically we did all the other stuff oh
and like you know in the film there's an
aerial shot of me summiting um but it's
illegal to f a helicopter in us and they
they went all the way to the head of the
park service in Washington DC trying to
get permission to fly a drone never got
permission it's illegal to use drones in
the Park which is great which I think is
an appropriate rule but in this case but
well so in this case though it would
have been a lot better to fly drone but
so as it turns out the legal flight
ceiling for Eed is is either 1 or 2,000
feet above the rim of the valley and ELC
cap is the rim of the valley so
basically using a clex like a giant long
lens in a helicopter 1,000 ft above ELC
cap they were able to shoot it like
normal and it's technically legal but
very much outside the like we kind of
knew that that was well we I had nothing
to do with this like you know but the
the the crew kind of knew that that
would burn some bridges at the park
because that's very much outside the
scope of of what you're supposed to do
in National Park M as it should be but
you know they tried every other way and
they were like we need aerial footage
and so basically the very last thing we
did we did five more days of film we did
whatever and then I resoed the last 600
ft um like two or three times in a row
for the helicopter as like our last
thing and then we all like wrapped and
then we all fled the
park again this makes me super mad dude
this this every time I hear you about
you reenacting stuff and it makes me mad
I get frustrated I get mad look dude I
cannot imagine being like hey broke can
you just get that one more time hold on
take off your harness and get it again
oh talk about a burden yeah well so I
did some of the the the posing so like I
don't want to give the wrong idea that
like the film is faked or posed or
anything because it's not I mean it like
they have a long shot of me doing the
entire clim and it's all but then we
went back and and reshot some of the
sections or reshot Stills so some of the
things I did that when we were back
posing um I would I had like a little
tiny like a belt basically under
underneath my pants and so for a couple
of the shots I had a rope going down my
pant leg and then like in a big loop of
slack going out of the frame and so then
you could do like a bunch of stuff and
still be you could still be attached but
with this sort of catastrophe system
where if you fell it would rip your
pants off and you'd get caught by the
basically like a seat belt around your
waist and so like you would survive but
it would be catastrophic you know like
your pants would tear off like
everything would be bad and you'd be
like ow you know it' be super painful
but you wouldn't die at least but so
there were a couple sections of the root
that I did you know six times in a row
over and over with this giant like death
Loop of slack out and I'm kind of like
like this isn't that much less scary
than just SOL I again you know I was
like this is kind of extreme were you
miked up on the real one um for from the
boulder up or something basically at a
certain point I put on a mic yeah like
when I pass some of the crew somewhere
so I actually was listening to music off
my phone for a lot of it because that's
like I like to do that when I'm sing but
you can't really do that when you're
miked because they're not going to
license a bunch of like '90s metal and
stuff and so they're like oh he licensed
a bunch of tool like you know Metallica
like cuz you're breathing in the boulder
problem you can
hear yeah that uh I forget if I was
miked for the Bold or not yeah well what
whatever they did it definitely I was
also miked for tons of other climbs so
they have tons of audio of me just
trying hard climbing it's like who knows
like what it's from but um but yeah I
was miked for part of it but part of it
I wasn't miked for because I kind of
didn't want the like I didn't want
weight you know like you have like a
transmitter on you the whole time like
you have extra stuff you feel the cable
on you it's just like another thing that
you're sort of like I just don't want
like don't feel like I got caught up in
a cable you know and Jimmy Jim wasn't
like cripping a diva dude yeah totally
no I mean there you know that's the hard
thing is that they didn't want to
compromise the climate experience he
seemed like the he seemed like you know
he handled it as good as a human being
could handle he certainly did his best
you do what you you do what you got to
do like I mean he's a climber and he
totally understands like the you know he
doesn't want to compromise my climbing
experience he also wants to make a great
film and and he doesn't want to
compromise the the ethics of it all you
know wants it to be real I mean it's
yeah it's super hard it's a hard film to
make MH I mean you know so they actually
kept me incredibly well insulated from
the like most of what I know about the
film making process I sort of learned
afterward during the tour because we
were all doing events together and like
talking about the cinematography and
talking about all the stuff you know
that was all just sort of the Hollywood
tour but during the process they kept me
incredibly well insulated from from the
whole production side of it so I would
stay in my van by myself production
would all be in in a rented house like
doing their own thing and you know
they're up until like midnight dumping
footage and erasing cards and like
changing lenses and packing bags and
doing all the stuff and they're like
working and then getting up at like
freaking 3 to hike up the mountain and
repel in and meanwhile I'm just like
chilling in my van you know just like
doing my thing but that's kind of how it
had to be because it had to be the real
you know like I had to just be working
on my climbing project and they just had
to be
documenting but yeah I mean it's a crazy
it's it was it was a whole crazy process
so going back to like when did it set in
that
you you I mean obviously you understand
the
freaking the the gravity of the
situation of you making it but then you
make it is it still like how long does
it take before you're like damn I I'm
I'm kind of like I'm kind of legendary
right now I'm kind of a legend right now
well so in the climbing scene you kind
of knew immediately like this is a big
deal for climbing but you know nobody
could have guessed that the film so the
film wasn't released until 2018 the next
year and then even then the film is
released but you know it's a it's a
documentary about rock climbing like who
knows how that's going to do but then it
did really well at film festivals and
then it did um then the theatrical
release was better than expected and
then it went bigger than expected and
then it went to IM and then it freaking
won an Oscar and so the whole you know
kind of snowballed basically and by the
time we won at the Oscars you're sort of
like this might be kind of a thing you
you're like holy [__] like this is
really taking off but you know but
before that I mean who whoever would
have guessed that climbing would be so
mainstream like that you know it's like
you just I mean there was no real
precedent for that I mean there's yeah
nothing yeah I never would have guessed
did your did you how about like
financially did your financial World
change dramatically or was it a slow
build I would say it changed
dramatically after the film I mean it's
hard to say in one way it didn't change
at all because I was already I already
was making what I needed and I was
already doing exactly what I wanted so
in terms of Lifestyle like nothing
changed at all but in terms of you know
Financial Security and freedom and
taking care of the family yeah it's
totally insane because like corporate
speaking I'm sure you know all that kind
of stuff like making appearances and
giving talks and and like doing public
things I mean once once you're like
you're the guy from the movie you know
you're like yeah cool you can go go give
talks about being the guy in the movie I
mean like man been a lot of uh you know
a lot of like CEO kind of folks that are
like oh yeah you're the guy that that
freestyled in Yellowstone and you're
like oh man you're like but you're like
yeah yeah no I'm I'm the freestyle guy
in Yellowstone the place with the
geysers you know it's cool yeah have you
been there with Buffalo it's it's nice
like big herds big herds of
Buffalo uh when was it that you did the
speed Rec record that was 2018 2019 it
was like the next year or oh it was the
next year okay I think so there's like a
competitive Drive you're a mellow dude
but there's obviously like a a little
thread of competitiveness thats through
you yeah for sure I mean if you also
part of it is if you think that you can
do something that other people can't do
it's almost like an obligation that you
know you have to do it no I mean to me I
I I do feel that a little bit with
climbing history climbing what whatever
it's like there are certain things that
I feel like I'm better suited for and
and just frankly better at than than
than some others in climbing I'm sort of
like oh I feel an obligation to do the
things that I'm able to
do you feel how much of it is just you
got the perfect genetic uh makeup for
this let me give you an
example some people are really explosive
right they got like explosive like
they're meant for wrestling right
they're just explosive some people have
really what is it slow twitch muscles
and they're really good at
endurance uh I'm really weird have you
ever heard of medium twitch muscle well
it's like it's a newer thing yeah it's
in between that's kind of what I have I
was never like a the fastest Sprinter
and I wasn't the best at the endurance
but what I would do really good is put
on a ruck sack with weight in it and be
able to go like pretty much indefinitely
you're built for the freaking arms arm
Services yeah yeah no like legitim Ely
like that's I was about to say the Army
and then I was like [__] I don't want to
get stabbed with one of these knives I
was like [__] the Navy the Navy and then
like uh I I don't need to sleep a lot so
for the job that I went into it was like
oh this is you found your calling yeah
was so nice to like be able to have some
of the things like if you need to sleep
all the time and you're in the military
much less the sealed teams like it's
going to be a lot harder on you whereas
if it's not that big of a deal then then
cool so you know you mention earlier
like oh there's people that are better
at this part of this type of climbing
and that other type of climbing and this
other type of climbing whereas you're
the type of climbing like you're going
to go 3,000 ft no rope like that's what
you're doing do you feel like you're the
like your
genetics are built for that I don't know
I mean what what you know what genetics
make you so I think that if if I have
any natural gift for climbing I think
it's actually just more of a like my
psych my my desire for it my love of it
because I mean I don't really have any
physical gifts you know nobody in my
family is an athlete like nobody's
nobody's gifted in any way you know I
was never winning competitions I was
never I was never great in that way but
what I've always had is I just love
freaking climbing you know like and I've
Loved climbing enough for almost 30
years now that I've been willing to do
it five or six days a week like a couple
of my friends have said I I would never
make this claim for sure but a few of my
friends have sort of AR and it could be
true I've maybe done more climbing than
almost anybody else on Earth because
because I favor these big endurance sort
of things like I like doing a lot of
climbing and I've been doing that
non-stop for you know 20 or 30 years now
you know I'm like that is a lot of
freaking climbing and and as it turns
out I think that that type of mileage
like that volume is maybe one of the
most important things for free soling
because in order to free solo and it it
might not be necessary I'm sure other
people could take a different path to
success as a solist but for me it's hard
to free Sol without feeling confident on
rock and it's hard to build confidence
on Rock without just a ton of time on
Rock like feeling consistent feeling you
know just feeling at home on in vertical
terrain and so I think that having that
that passion for climbing has probably
been the most important thing for me
it's like being willing to practice all
the time for many many years yeah I was
watching your master
class and uh one of the things your in
your master class you're talking about
your half crimp is weak or was weak and
you it's got a lot better it's it's much
better than it used to be and and what
was funny was I was thinking about my
entire climbing career of being a total
loser on climbing but you're like yeah I
was weak at this and I was like that's
the way everything felt to me when I try
CL be like no this is all horrible so
you have a weakness what' you do about
it oh well yeah I trained it it's gotten
better over time yeah I mean basically
certain grips like I mean this is like
way too Niche for a mainstream audience
but basically there's certain types of
ways that you hold your hand that I used
to be I used to think that there was
like something about particular types of
holds that just forced my hand open you
know I was like there's something wrong
with that hold but then come to find out
it was there's something wrong with my
hand you know that it's just really
[__] weak I was like oh that's too
bad you know it just turns out that it's
not the shape of the hold it's that I'm
very weak in this kind of in between
grip and so but that in between group
grip is what you typically use on a
hangboard like on a training tool and
I've now trained more consistently for
for many years which is funny because I
guess it's been like at least five or
six years now that I've been like
training more
and and I am much stronger in that
position now and so like that type of
hold now feels totally normal to me I'm
like oh it turns out there's nothing
wrong with The Rock I just had to get my
fingers a little
stronger there's another good quote in
that master class and it's actually both
you and Tommy kind of say it together or
one of you starts at the other but you
you guys talk about like one of the one
of the benefits of climbing is being
quote spiritually uplifted in the midst
of complete disaster and physical
hardship and it's like that right
there is such a good thing for humans
right to go through hard things and to
come out of them uplifted because
sometimes they're hard things that just
break you down and then leave you sort
of traumatized and and that's I mean
Tommy and I actually talk about this a
lot Tommy just spent a couple weeks for
their their kids school vacation at at
our place in Vegas and so I've been
climbing with the last couple weeks and
playing with the family and it's like
all been great playing with the kids
but we talk a lot about the the idea of
sort of elective hardship is what he
likes to phrase it but you know having
the the sort of luxury to be able to
choose to do hard things because you
know if hard things are being forced
upon you it's like not necessarily the
best growth opportunity but if you're in
a comfortable enough place in life that
you can choose to do hard things you
know on occasion things that push you
outside your comfort zone things that
things that challenge you in the right
ways then yeah those can be some of the
biggest growth experiences of your life
I guess but but you know it's all about
the right challenges
yeah and how often do the elective
challenges become un elective challenges
half through right I mean that happens
yeah I mean I have a I have a like a bit
of a family joke sort of that that all
my rest day hikes always wind up in some
sort of unplanned scramble you know
there's always like ropeless climbing at
the end of one of my hikes cuz like I
you know and it's not always true but it
does seem to happen that my rest day
hikes you know where I'm like I'm going
to go check out this other place or like
look at this thing and they almost
always went wind up with like oh and
then I had to climb over this thing or
you know and then like you know I once
descended I live uh outside of Las Vegas
um have you have you cled to Vegas ever
you never been there like um Red Rock
Canyon is like the big famous they're
basically the 3,000 foot Sandstone walls
like just outside of town I have been to
Red Rock clb yeah it's really pretty
it's it's beautiful it's a destination
but so those big mountains have like
canyoning routes and pretty technical
desense off some of them like full-on
like what you imagine Utah slot canyons
where you do you know 15 repels and like
swim through pools water and stuff
anyway so some of my rest day hikes have
ended in canyons and things like that by
accident where you're like oh I was
hiking and I was out of food and water
and I was just trying to get back to the
car and then I had to down climb 15
repels and then and then climb across
these pools and stuff cuz I don't want
to freaking swim cuz you're like in the
middle know you're like this is crazy
but yeah but that's the kind of elective
challenge that you're like you know yeah
you often get in over your head and it
becomes more than you expect but it's
still by choice yeah when does the when
does it get too too hot to climb in
Vegas it never really gets too too hot
because uh there's a mountain above town
that goes to 12,000 ft okay so you can
climb you know 8 or 9,000 ft in the
summer uh in full shade good wind it's
like you know basically it's I I mean I
live in Vegas for a reason it's the best
climate in the country yeah know I I
remember when you first moved to Vegas
and I read an article about you're like
explaining why you move there and you're
like oh there's just climbing everywhere
yeah everybody just thinks of the strip
and they're like why would you go to
Vegas and you're like Yeah The Strip is
is crazy but just outside of town is the
best climate in the country the strip is
actually even worse is when you go like
four blocks Off the Strip yeah and it's
like they're really sad like like light
industrial sort
of it's depressing yeah it's really Grim
it's it's like but the mountain access
in Vegas I think is the best in the
country I mean the it's insane like from
the from the Suburban edge of town like
you can be in full-on like Cookie Cutter
suburbs houses with like grocery stores
next to you you can drive 15 minutes to
a trail head and then you can like run
or bike for 15 minutes and you can be in
the middle of nowhere where you're never
going to see a soul and then you know
with like an hour of scrambling and
Hiking you can be back in some Canyons
where you're like I'm going to die alone
out here and no one will ever find my
body it's like it's crazy I mean in a
way that that's hard to experience like
anywhere like all the famous sort of
mountain cities in the US like you know
Salt Lake City or Denver things like
that most of those if you live in town
you have to drive for like an hour to
get to like the real nature part like
you can't be in the middle of nowhere
and even then there's so many people
that you know the trail hoods are
crowded the back country is crowded it's
like I don't know Vegas is insane mhm
how has your process of
domestication come along I mean how long
did you live in a van for I Liv in a van
uh by myself basically for 10ish years
and then I had a different van um for
another fiveish years sort of maybe 15
years on and off in the van and then I
bought a house with my now wife and now
we have an almost 2-year-old and yeah
domestication is uh strongly on on track
I'm domesticating for
sure and you're not losing mind too bad
no it's funny you know sometimes I'm
like should I be more upset about this
or like should I be chafing but I I kind
of like it like my daughter's great I'm
having a good time I'm training I'm
climbing I feel like I'm still able to
do all the big climbing Adventures that
I want I think part of is that my Hunger
is way diminished for it MH and part of
that I'm like oh is that because I'm
losing my fire am I losing my Edge but I
think part of that is because I've done
many of the things that I want to do and
I'm just kind of like you know if there
was like a longer list of classic Roots
around the Western us that I hadn't done
then you know I'd probably be more
excited but I'm like I don't know I've
done a lot you know I'm sort of like
I've done a lot of the things I want to
do and um I don't know I like I like
dading I like training at home I'm just
like I don't know it's fine you say you
like dading yeah ding yeah like
verb yeah well you're already done
dading almost so yeah I'm almost done
you're practically done Y and hopefully
like I said hopefully people can learn
learn from my mistakes there so I don't
and not train their kids for hours a day
and jiujitsu you're like weirdly every
time I punch my kid in the face he get
upset about it so I just you know I
didn't even break his arm it just felt
like it was going to break I'm like I
don't know what he's so pissed
about you kind of in that 10 to 15 years
living in your van you I would say you
you must have pretty much mastered like
the minimalist LIF style yeah for sure
though though it doesn't feel like
you're you're basically just you know
the goal is always to climb as much as
possible and so you're doing whatever is
required to climb as much as you can and
nothing else matters really and so it's
not like you're embracing minimalism to
be a minimalist it's just that you don't
need anything you know mean that's kind
of it's like you're a true minimalist
cuz you're like whatever just don't need
it yeah people are like oh you know
living in a van is that hard you're like
well I mean the van yeah I mean it's
it's nicer to have a shower or something
in your house but it's hard to beat the
backyard because with a van it's like
you just open the door and you're in the
most beautiful places and if the weather
gets bad you go to the next place and
it's like you're just sort of floating
between the best destinations in the
whole Western us all year long like it's
kind of amazing not a bad gig yeah it's
it's a really really nice gig I mean I
do I do still sort of fondly miss that
you know when you're deep in D like
you're changing diapers and my wife's
pregnant right now and it's like a lot
going on at the house you're sort of
like man I used to just sit in the van
by myself doing nothing all day on a
rest day it's like that sounds
nice and what about the uh the honold
foundation
that you I think um when you talk about
it you went to a trip to Chad and that
was sort of the the inspo behind that
that was part of it I mean yeah the trip
to Chad was my first trip to Africa was
like in 2009 but but really so the H
Foundation supports Community solar
projects around the world and um
basically it's like we give grants to to
community nonprofits that that then use
solar to to sort of better their lives
in various ways and around the so it's
been over 10 years of supporting solar
projects around the world and so I
started the foundation I guess in 2012
is a little more than 10 years um and I
basically just wanted to do something
positive for the environment you know I
mean as a climber you're just Outdoors
Non-Stop and you know I was worried
about climate change worried about
environmental degradation in general and
just sort of like you know you want to
do something useful for for planet Earth
but I also sort of realized that there's
no point in helping the environment that
doesn't help humans as well I mean so
like that expedition to Chad in
particular you see human population is
living in just the I mean just the Grim
just abject poverty you know it's the
grimmest condition in a way it's almost
not even fair to say poverty because
like there's no market economy at all
you know it's like not fair to say
they're poor because like there money
doesn't even factor into their lifestyle
at all because there's nothing to buy
because they're so remote and so rural
it's like you know it's just people
hurting goats in the desert and just
surviving and you know handful climate
expeditions to places like that and
realizing you know I mean I was reading
a lot of sort of environmental
non-fiction and and just non-fiction in
general and you know there's something
like a billion people on Earth without
access to uh to to
power and you know I mean basically
there are a billion people on Earth in
poverty that are sort of you know I mean
the the world is constantly getting
richer and sort of you know progressing
getting more comfortable except for the
sort of billion is people who are
largely left behind and you know I just
felt like if I was going to be
supporting environmental nonprofits like
putting money toward the environment had
to help that those billion people as
well so anyway that's basically where
the H Foundation came from and and
that's just about getting power to to
these people yeah sometimes power I mean
sometimes that means lights like if
you're in rural places in Africa it's
like realistically the grid is never
going to get there um it'll never be
cost effective so like solar power
Lantern solar power in home systems um
sometimes that means more robust systems
uh you know like Refrigeration in real
places like uh like agricultural
processing you know B you know I mean
there Limitless things that people use
power for and so I mean now so last year
the H Foundation actually the last
couple years we will have given um over
2 million in Grants to to different
organizations around the world and
normally the grants range from like 50
to 20000k let's say and you know so it's
not like huge money it's like relatively
small scale projects but that can be
enough to like completely transform
somebody's life because I mean
especially when you're in rural villages
in Africa I mean if you get light for
the first time like that's a big deal
because in I mean I mean you know in the
tropics it's dark for 12 hours a day MH
and so you know if you suddenly have an
extra four or five four or five
productive hours a day I mean that's
that's a big deal for kids going to
school for people for people just living
you know just like having a nice life
like having a light is a big deal and
then like having a radio having a
refrigerator like having basic you know
appliances
anyway yeah the projects vary the the
scope varies we're we're trying to do as
much as we can I don't know I'm just I'm
just rambling it's like it's just it's
there's this crazy pipeline of projects
there we get so many applications
so what I was trying to say was that we
can vet the applications by the the
projects that have the most sort of
win-win like added benefits where it's
like oh you're using solar to do this
thing that's also good in this other way
like there's also a Workforce
Development component or like it's also
the local people learning skills to do
to do such and such servic systems it's
like we kind of get our our pick of the
Litter with the projects that we're
funding because there's such a huge
demand and you know realistically we
just can't fund that you know like we
don't I'm a climber like I don't make
that much I'm not like a tech
billionaire I kind of wish I was because
it'd be nice to to distribute the money
better but um but yeah so anyway we can
choose like the most win-win sorts of
projects yeah and even you know doing
civil Affairs projects overseas when I
was in the military like $50,000
$100,000 invested into a community
that's like a it's a yeah it's a massive
Game Changer so totally that's awesome
what what does your day look like like
to you know not today but like what's a
normal day look for you look like for
you right now well so right now my wife
is uh is due with our second child in
six weeks so so I'm kind of settled at
home it's also like it's the holiday
season there have been a lot of folks
and family coming and it's like chill at
home um so I've been in this this
routine at home where I'm climbing
Outdoors at this this cave that I've
been climbing at um trying this hard
project like this rout that I can't do
and I've been trying for two months
still haven't done it but it's it's
really hard um but uh and so I go to the
cave one day I train in like a home gym
one day and then I rest one day and my
rest days are sometimes like
supplemental workout stuff like you know
shoulder PT stuff and um sometimes run a
little bit sometimes just bed rest just
depends on how worked I am from the
other two days but so basically it's a
3-day cycle that just repeats at nauseum
for the last two
months and then when the baby's born uh
are are you I mean do you have other
projects that you're looking out in the
next
years this year so the last two years
were both sort of built around these big
summer Expeditions that I went on so two
summers ago I went on a six week trip to
Greenland which became a TV show for
National Geographic which actually comes
out pretty soon in February I think and
then this summer I did a two-month Bike
Tour to Alaska uh with Tommy Caldwell so
we bike like 2400 miles and we climb big
walls along the way and it was it was
funny that with the Greenland trip my
wife and I were like you know what 6
weeks away from the family it's too long
like not going to do that again that was
too much cuz we were in the most remote
part of Eastern Greenland like totally
out of touch like 6 weeks away it was it
was a lot because we had the new baby
and so we were like not doing that again
and then the next summer I'm gone for 2
months we're like [__] it was like kind
of kind of a botch and and then that
trip you know my wife is now pregnant
and our daughter is like a year old and
it's all sort of it's like a lot so
anyway but that's also going to be a TV
show for National Geographic probably
next year or something whenever they
finish making it but so so what I'm
saying though the last two years have
been sort of focused on these big big
Expedition TV project things um and then
you know as much personal climbing as I
can fit around family and everything as
well this year I think it's unlikely
that I'll do a big Expedition like that
just because uh because the TV schedule
like the things are being released this
year it doesn't really make sense to do
another one straight away and I don't
know if I quite have the appetite for it
because the two-month bicycle trip to
Alaska as it turns out took me several
months to recover from and like to
regain Fitness from and um I kind of dug
myself into a hole biking 2,000 miles so
I get fast as we could to like we we
just got kind of worked how much
training did you do for the bike part
literally none I did 100 mile ride just
to make sure that I could and then uh
but I do have a bit of a biking not base
but I've done a couple bike tours back
in the day and uh and for several years
before I was living on my van I didn't
have a car so I was biking a ton and so
I have a little bit more of a biking
base than than other things but um but
no I got so crushed it was terrible it
was it was terrible so in recovery
mode way yeah that's the thing and
honestly like so I'm 38 now and I don't
consider myself old yet but I am like
recovery is slower than it was in my mid
20s and it's hard to say how much of
that is age and how much of that is like
having a young daughter and like you
know just family stuff and just a
different lifestyle and whatever yeah
but um but I'm sort of like a lot of the
recovery like recovering from the Bike
Tour I would have thought like oh maybe
like a month maybe two and you know it's
more like maybe three until I actually
feel better and I'm kind of like yeah
and the grand scheme things like that's
fine you know what's three months but
but it would have been nice to recover
in 3 weeks you know well would you
mention that Bas thing right cuz I
remember when I like going through SEAL
training like you run you run so much
you run just going to eat is six miles a
day so just just running to the it's
like a mile to the chow hall and then a
mile back so you do that three times a
day so just without any part of the
training you're running six miles a day
so you basically that is totally crazy
why why not uh why not sleep a little
closer to the to the
running so but you build up this base
where you know when I was I wouldn't run
for months or what for whatever reason
or would run for a month you just go out
and run and just make it happen but then
you get a little older you're like yo
all a sudden someone puts a watch on you
and you're like all right let's we're
going to run Four Mile time run you're
like oh yeah no problem and you're like
yo what happened what happened to my
quote unquote base it ain't there no
more it's funny you say that cuz
actually so I said I've been hanging out
with Tommy and um how old Tommy he's
eight years older than you um I think he
might 7 he might be 45 maybe he's 44 I
think he's 45 but anyway yeah he's a bit
older and he actually tore his Achilles
Last year so he went through like a year
and a half recovery process because it
ruptured two other times so basically he
tore his a killes three times and it was
the whole process to like get it better
and uh so and that's part of the reason
we did the bike adventure together
because he'd been biking a lot as part
of his PT and he was all fired up on
biking and he was chomping at the bit to
have a huge Adventure because he has two
kids who are you know 10 and seven and
so he hadn't done any big trips B since
he had his family and then he he was
overcoming this injury and he was biking
a lot he was like I'm fired up to do
something epic and I was kind of like
I've been doing Expeditions every year
and I'm a little more tired and I was
like man I'm just not quite at the same
level that he is for like this this kind
of Adventure I was like this is this is
a lot but how do he hurt his Achilles
sometimes people hurt their Achilles
they were like I was grabbing a bag of
groceries and my achilles blew out no he
took this kind of Epic fall climbing I
mean it was a normal lead fall where a
rope caught him but he came into the
wall one footed and the foot that hit
the wall ruptured the Achilles ruptured
and he said he immediately was like oh
you know my ailles just ruptured and
then had to like hop all back down from
the mountain but yeah was like when you
watch the video it is like a normal lead
fall fall sort of but he like swings in
all crazy leading with one foot and then
hits the wall one footed and you're like
oh God you know like I think even if his
Achilles hadn't ruptured I think it
would have hurt his ankle a bit you know
cuz like you're hitting the wall pretty
hard with one foot but swinging in all
but once again rock climbing is safe
it's for the family yeah yeah no it's
totally safe you'll be good to go
totally safe though he was doing
something uh very difficult like kind of
Cutting Edge yeah exactly that's and if
you're doing that kind of climbing yeah
there's a higher probability or and even
still he wasn't really hurt I mean the
thing is he's had like Achilles issues
his Achilles were tight he's a
middle-aged man you know he probably
should have been stretching a little
more but no but I was going to say
though that with the the two of us
talking about Bas like so the two of us
have been climbing together a ton and
both of us have always had a good
endurance based climbing um like good
stamina and I think both of us are
trying to be like I'm not sure if the
base is like quite what we thought it
was you know like you've always just
counted on it being in the bank and now
we're like I think our I think our
accounts are empty you know we got to
like start rebuilding some endurance and
like so both of us are kind of like
rebuilding some climbing like some base
climbing Fitness that that we've always
just sort of counted on but we're like
it could be better maybe yeah it's wild
watching you guys do that speedrun up l
cap the way you guys are just freaking
breathing like you're sprinting yeah
yeah though I mean it's still
objectively very slow it's still 2 hours
to do 3,000 ft of vertical so it's like
you know I was thinking about that too
like if if I was going to go for a run
right now and it's was like hey this is
a we're going for a run it's 3,000 feet
of vertical you're like oh that's like
that's a that's a kick in the nuts run
kind of but you could probably run that
in 45 minutes maybe or like something
like that it still is a gut check yeah
it you know it' be hard work for sure
but okay well here you want a fun
thought experiment so so the I mean this
is also really Niche but an interesting
thing to think about it so um so I wrote
up an article about the no speed record
at some point and I was on a plane and
didn't have internet but it just doing
back of the envelope math was like okay
if you compare uh Elite sprinting to
Elite marathoning you know so 100 meter
sprint to the to the marathon and you
compare the times like so I did all the
math on you know meters per second and
so basically the marathon pace is
roughly half of the sprinting pace so I
was like okay so if you take the 2hour
nose Ascent which is kind of comparable
to the marathon and then there's
actually a World Cup speed climb which
is a 15 M vertical wall that people that
the world record for men is like roughly
5 seconds so it's kind of similar to the
100 meter sprint and I was like so if
you take the same half that pace and
when when you watch World Cup speed
climbers climbing it looks like a monkey
or something looks totally insane yeah
it's totally insane it's it's it's
incredibly fast but I was like so if you
took physiologically though if you took
half that pace and you applied it to LC
cap how long do you think it would take
to climb LC cap I don't know what's the
math uh is either 8 or 12 minutes I
forget but but yeah so it's like
basically 10 minutes to climb out cap so
so I concluded My article with like you
know while we're very proud of two hours
and we tried hard and it's a good effort
we're sort of like it's very far from
the physiological limits of like the
conceivable like what somebody could do
on a you know on a 3,000 foot wall I
think that that somebody could go down
to like 145 or an hour and a half at
some point obviously you can never go
down to 10 minutes because there's gear
in this rope and there's safety
considerations and you know you're still
climbing this crazy wall but I was kind
of like uh the physiological limits are
much
further well you've done a lot but it
sounds like you're not even close to
where you could be but that's ex that's
exactly that's exactly I know I'm like
after 20 years of effort all I've
learned is that I'm so far from what I
could have been I should have been
training harder the whole time well
there's there's a clip in in the movie
one of the movies when you when you make
that and um you're on the phone with
Tommy uh I think his wife and she's like
are are you going to cry and you said no
that feeling is passed I feel like we
suck and should have done done better
and that's that's where you're basically
at so yeah EXA exactly exactly well
awesome stuff you are we up to speed
ises that get us up to speed that
basically gets us to Modern Life I mean
that gets us to the holiday season just
trying to build some Fitness I don't
know yeah it's I was saying the the the
TV the Expeditions that I've done the
last two years I mean both of those I
think will release this year which in
some ways buys me as a professional
climber it buys me like a year or two of
having to actually do anything in a way
because there's like content coming out
like there's a movie coming out like I
think uh February for the Greenland
piece uh and then you know potentially
later in the fall for for the Alaska
Expedition with Tommy and and so you
know it takes some pressure off feeling
like you have to like do something that
year or like create something cool but
that basically means that I can just
keep grinding away at the schedule that
I've been on this sort of like three-day
which I'm kind of into because I've been
really enjoying myself and it's a nice
way to stay with the fam and like be at
home and and just grind cuz I I love
like I love just climbing two on one off
two on went off like I could do that the
whole rest of my life and be
happy and and it's interesting I'm
curious to see if I'm going to improve a
lot from it or not because like in a way
just like grinding away and training
like my arms have basically been very
sore for two months straight now I'm
kind of like eventually I'm going to get
much stronger you know I think I don't
know if it'll take two months or four
months or 6 months but I like doing it
and I don't mind waiting and you know
we'll just wait and see like how it
plays out so I'm I'm pretty psyched in
in a way having the films come out gives
me sort of this buffer to just like keep
training and definitely while the new
child comes and and we just like keep
settling into home life so I don't know
we'll see I it's less glamorous than
being like I just roam the west coast
and do Cutting Edge free solos whenever
I want but I'm like I still really like
it you know it's like it's a really nice
I don't know do you have a way of
measuring like pragmatically your
strength like do you do finger hang for
this amount of time with these two
digits and yeah hangs with weight is
like one simple way it's basically
weightlifting both with hangs um and
then also like training boards like uh
you know steep boards where you're like
doing Boulder problems for certain
grades like that's an easy way to sort
of measure but but also a big part of it
is the sensations of like how do you
feel when climbing cuz there are times
when you feel kind of weightless and
you're just like oh like I feel great
and then there are times when you're
like I just kind of suck you know like
to me it's the sensation of doing
something you didn't think you could do
CU like often you'll pull on two holds
and you'll look up and you be like
there's no way I could like make it to
that hole there's no way I could catch
that but then you try anyway and then
occasionally you stick something that
you're sure you couldn't do and to me
that's like the best feeling CL when
you're like I knew I couldn't do it but
I tried anyway and I did it was a
miracle you know like that's so cool and
two months into this cycle do you feel
like you can hold more weight when
you're hanging and you feel Improvement
right now yeah objectively nothing great
yet like get in there get in there we'll
see how's your diet are you get enough
protein yeah I think so I've been um
I've been doing all kinds of diet like
experimentation and playing around and
and uh yeah I think I think it's good
I've been like sleeping enough you know
very health clean lifestyle you know the
baby goes to about at 700 we're in bed
at like 8:30 it's like it's all pretty
yeah it's all uh but that's it's funny
daddy well exactly yeah Dad Dad yeah
well that's the thing is it sounds so
boring but I I kind of like it you know
it's like it's a great lifestyle and
yeah allows me to climb like the way I
want I don't know yesterday uh because
because I was coming here to chat with
you today uh like today would have been
a day at the cave but I was kind of like
oh I won't be in town so yesterday I
climbed as a day three but day three is
always kind of useless cuz you're so
tired from the first two days so um so I
went with my wife to like a beautiful
sunny wall and we just climbed like a
bunch of rots and my wife is very
pregnant right now so she just uh was
climbing on top rope and like just
having fun in the sun and I was like man
it's so fun to just go to a cliff that
we haven't been to in a while and just
climb tons of roots you know I did like
15 Roots yesterday or something and so
kind of like a fun volume day just to
like see how you feel and just have fun
climbing how long is the session in the
cave in the the hard cave that I'm going
to um normally like I don't know 6 hours
or less or something but the thing is
you aren't actually climbing the whole
time cuz like you drive there you hike
up you get to the cave basically I do
six roots in a day like two warm-ups and
then four hard things then I go home is
like the uh the aspiration or or maybe
sometimes five Roots like one warm up
and four hard things and then go home
and that's where you're at that's all I
do and that's the thing it's It's a
Grind because it's like you just go you
fail and then you go home and like my
last day up there I went up and it was
freezing cold like bitterly cold and so
I failed because I was too weak but I
also failed because my skin felt like
glass cuz like with you know it was like
0% humidity and and freezing cold and so
it means that your skin like feels
incredibly dry and hard and you like
can't even interface with the rock like
you can't even touch it it's like feels
glassy and so then you're kind of like
well I failed because I'm weak but I
also failed because I can't even
freaking feel my fingers or toes and I
can't even touch the Rock and you're
just like Jesus and then you go home
feeling totally worked are you seeing
some progress though uh well I've kind
of seen negative progress on my cave
project but it's hard to say because
because the conditions have gotten way
worse um but no I'm seen progress on the
board like I don't know I I think it's
the right path but this is always the
challenge with training for a long time
is because you start to second guess the
path a little bit where you're like oh
am I on the correct you know it's like
because I assume with like all the
weightlifting and things that you do if
you're just like grinding for months at
a time you're not going to see big PRS
while you're grinding but then if you
take some time off and you chill then
you're probably going to feel a lot
better Y and so I'm kind of at that
point where it's like you don't want to
give up on the process cuz you think
it's the right process yep I was
literally just talking about this
yesterday like everyone says these days
like trust the process trust the process
and you're like cool and so you're like
I'm going to do what I got to do every
day I got to set up my schedule I got to
be disciplined about it but occasionally
you got to take a step back and be like
yo are you making progress if you're not
then that sucks yeah but you got to know
the time frame of like how much like how
long are you willing to work or like
wait for it yeah cuz sometimes that
progress is so slow and yet the path
you're on is the correct path exactly
but it still is like
a rough actually so on on the leadup to
free selling Al cap I had an experience
like that where I was like grinding for
months and all my friends were telling
me that it was like the bad path but all
of my friends are sort of professional
rock climbers where they care about
performance like they're trying to climb
hard grades and I wasn't really trying
to climb the hardest grades because I
was trying to free Sol out cap in a few
months which isn't the hardest grade you
know it's it's it's rated 512 or you
know 13 minus or whatever so like the
rating is Elite but not like not Cutting
Edge by any means and so was doing this
tremendous amount of volume and and as a
result was tired all the time and so I
was never really performing at my my
physical limit let's say and so my
friends are all like oh you should be
resting more so you can perform more at
your limit but I was kind of like that's
not really the point like that's not
what I'm training for and I kind of like
stuck my guns stuck to the path but then
you know several months into it by by
sheer whatever like part of being
professional climber like had some work
stuff or something for whatever reason
like took a break for several days
because I had like something going on
and then came back and felt like a total
hero was like yeah I had basically one
day outside where I was like it's
working I feel amazing and then I went
back to just like grinding for a couple
more months and then was in E just
grinding and then basically peaked for
the climb and then was done you know I
was like okay you know but basically
felt like I was sucking for 6 months
except for one day that was like a
signpost they're like you're doing okay
and then and then the climb itself how
much time did how much how many days did
you rest
before I don't even know um not not that
much I mean I was kind of like day on
day off
um it was interesting because I actually
had all the prep work was like okay I'm
ready I'm fired up and then it freaking
rained so like I was going to do it but
then it rained the forecast was bad and
you know rain that day and then and then
I wanted to repel the entire wall again
to make sure that nothing got wet and
you know I had chalk marks on keyh holds
here and there like sort of marking left
foot here right foot like you know cuz
on on a crack up a blank wall like it's
hard to remember if it's like your left
finger in there or your right finger in
there but sometimes it's like critical
which which way you do things so a lot
of it was like marked with chalk and the
chalk washes off if it rains and so I
wanted to make sure that it hadn't
rained too much because even though it
hadn't rain that much down Valley like
or up Valley in my van you never really
know you know a mile or two way it could
have just dumped on the summit and just
like pressure washed the entire upper
pitches and so so then I went and
repelled the whole wall to like double
check everything and it was all fine
everything was dry my chalk was there
but then you're tired from freaking
repelling the entire wall so then you're
like okay you need another rest day I
mean this is the challenging thing with
free soing is that like you want to sort
of strike while the Iron's hot but then
you know but then life gets in the way
and you're kind of like ah then you got
to start the whole cycle again I don't
know anyway so yeah I took a rest day
and then then went the day after but it
was like I'm all fired up and then it
rains and then you actually don't get to
go for another like three days or
something got to grind and you got to
rest Echo Charles over here is a big
proponent of rest days monitoring rest
yes you could say what you want we know
what's happening over there uh does that
get us up to speed now are we good yeah
I think we're good I think we're good
sorry I'm just rambling no it's it's all
good um people if people want to find
you look I've mentioned alone on the
wall we mentioned free solo like if you
haven't read this book if you haven't
watched those movies just go watch them
they're they're they're awesome they're
awesome stories it's awesome to see
again what I think
is I don't know what could be a a a a
harder feat by a human being but this is
right up there some somebody wants to
hit me up on social media and tell me
what was a more impressive feat I'm I'm
all yours I'm listening but check out
the movies uh you're on the interwebs
Alex hon.com you got your own podcast
indeed climbing
gold and you you bring on people from
history talk through trips that you've
done yeah this year I think we'll be
focusing on the the Olympics again okay
and climbing gold we originally created
it because of the because climbing
joined the Olympics in in 2020 for Tokyo
though though it happened in 2021
because of Co but um but basically we
created the podcast because we're like
this is a moment for climbing you know
going to the Olympics for the first time
feels like a big thing and could be a
big thing for the sport um and so this
year I think we'll be focused on the
Olympics again right on yeah we'll see
right on so tune in to that you're on
Instagram you're on Twitter you're on
Facebook Alex honold it's h o n n o l d
you're on master class too indeed got to
mention that uh eeko Charles you got any
questions yeah I got some questions you
me what is crimping crimping half CRI is
that what's the what's the term it's
just the it's the way you Hold Your Hand
it's like a half it's like the way you
hold an edge like this yeah but uh but
yeah crimping just refers to how you
hold your fingers on an edge so what's
half crimping half crimping means the so
full crimping imagine this is oh here
I'll use the edge of the knife this is
this is like a good Edge so full
crimping is with your thumb over your
fing fingers like crimping half crimping
would be just your fingers halfway like
this and then open hand would be like
this like draping off of it like oh dang
dang okay all right and I notice your
hands like you know how like in
Jiu-Jitsu right if you're the ghee guy
you get like crooked fingers Knuckles
whatever uh cauliflower ear right is
this like and it's actually not your
hand it looks like it's your fingers
that are like real muscular yeah but I
don't think they're actually muscles in
your fingers I think my fingers are just
kind of fat just big are they would they
you think I mean you've been climbing
since 10 years climbing a long time yeah
I think I think I probably would have
had pretty big hands just by Nature cuz
my my dad and my grandpa have like big
hands yeah but um but also I think your
connective tissue gets bigger like it's
like cranking sideways on your fingers
Non-Stop and cracks like I think you get
though I'm going to bet you have some
big old hands too pretty normal
sizeer hypertrophy in your fingers yeah
I've noticed yeah probably yeah yeah
impressive you know but I mean if you
saw like a stone Mason that worked their
whole life like chipping Stone you like
yeah they're going to have some big old
Ms it's just hard work with your hands
also probably some percentages is
probably calling and stuff you probably
sand it all off it's just like extra
skin sand off the fingers well no I mean
yeah your tips like you're my tips CU
like so much well I mean that's why like
you know I was joking but crimping the
edge of this knife like I can't actually
feel this that that well yeah you know
bed I mean this isn't sharp though huh
not not that sharp it's it if you don't
know this Echo Charles like yeah rock
climbing is up painful sport fre painful
Muay Thai do you know what Muay Thai is
yeah likei it's like
kickboxing that is a painful sport too
like get kicked kicked you're getting
kicked in the legs you actually you do
things to deaden the nerves and your
shins it's it's but it's a very very
painful sport but rock climbing is also
like just there's there's pain you have
rocking is painful in like a way that
feels kind of light duty compared to
like Combat Sports where you're like
getting hit climbing hurts in a way
where like oh your skin hurts and like
the tips of your toes hurt and when
you're in the sun like climbing shoes
are really tight black rubber and it's
like your toes will be burning and so
it's like your fingers and toes are
burning and uncomfortable and just like
you're holding I mean some some climbing
hes are literally like the edge of some
of these knives like the back edge of
this knife would be like like something
you're just pulling as hard as you can
it feels like it's cutting your
fingertips it's just like it's painful
but in a way that's like very
unglamorous you know it's not like it
punch in the face like it doesn't seem
like it should be that painful but
you're like man it just you just you're
like wow it's it is freaking painful
it's I'm here to tell you it's freaking
painful so like gloves that's like is
that a big no no can't because uh you
lose the sensitivity you can't like yeah
I mean if you think grabbing tiny little
things it just tears the gloves like
it's better better to have the skin
makes sense they'd be like trying to
play guitar with gloves just a
non-starter yeahhuh I mean in extreme
cold like I have climbing gloves like
I've done two expeditions to Antarctica
and normally I would climb all the easy
train in gloves because if it's easy
enough it doesn't really matter but then
normally when you get to the hard stuff
you basically pull your gloves off with
your teeth and then like climb
barehanded for a bit and then try to put
your gloves back on oh yeah you it's
like but I mean it's it's how you try to
save your skin if you're in like Subzero
temps you know it's like it's pretty
unpleasant to climb in to rock climb in
Antarctica what else Echo Charles uh you
watch movies yeah what's your gem
Cliffhanger you ever watch that one dude
bro
cffh actually so so fun fact so
Cliffhanger is Loosely based on on a
story on on like real events in used and
and actually my podcast com in Gold we
did Deep dive into that whole story like
this uh in the 1970s a plane carrying $2
million with the marijuana crash landed
in a lake in eede and in Valley Uprising
right yeah it's in Valley Uprising so we
did this deep dive where we interviewed
all the people involved because a bunch
of climbing like dirt bag guys that are
like living in a tent with like no
possessions all hik in the back and come
out with like Bales and bales of
marijuana which they then dry and then
sell and uh so then all of a sudden
bunch of climbers like driving sports
cars and like going to Europe and like
doing anyway it's a classic story but
yeah Cliffhanger is a great movie H yeah
that was that's all I got that's all you
got yeah that was it that was it come on
man it's good to meet you yeah Alex any
closing thoughts man no no just a
pleasure chatting you know just I what a
scene I mean I do my podcast like in my
actual closet in my house it's like a
tiny little thing and I just look at a
wall and I'm like maybe I need more
climbing accessories and like cool stuff
you know it's like it sets a mood
there's a there's a real mood in here
that that my closet
lags well this one definitely started
this used to be the maintenance closet
and it was half this size and then we
recorded in the maintenance closet for a
while and then eventually we once we had
that little desk over there with a bunch
of crap uh getting piled up on it the
podcast place was a little too small so
we made it this big but what's crazy is
you go and talk to you go you know like
when you did your Hollywood tour and
you'd go to whatever major broadcast
network and they've got got 12 people in
the back room like looking at you
through the glass and all these cameras
and everything they don't more people
listen to this than that which is nuts
right freaking Echo Charles with his
thousand worth of equipment presses
record and more people listen to this
than listen to whatever that major
broadcast is so eka Charles does the
work at 12 men is what you're saying oh
see my man right here he knows bro
that's when you know I don't
know I doubt it uh well I thought he was
going to chime in early when you were
talking about you know guys are prepping
cameras and downloading cards and
scrubbing I was like oh he's going to
echo's going to chime in with how hard
his job is and you know I'm just over
here climbing freaking l cap right
that's what's happening freaking echo's
just pressing record that's the way it's
going down uh anything else though no no
pleasure actually yeah I I want to look
around the gym a little more after this
I ask a few questions oh yeah what if he
jumped in the G Jiu-Jitsu you would have
automatic Advantage Advantage with those
with your hands no but I'm pretty I
don't want to hurt my you wouldn't do it
twist them all even like even if I go to
like a massage parlor I'm always like
don't touch my hands you know when
people are like oh I'm going to crack
your knuckles I'm like no don't mess my
fingers cuz like at any given time you
know I always have one finger that hurts
a little bit in some way and you're
always like kind of like taking care of
a few things I'm like no Nobody messes
with my hands you ice your hands or
anything like that do you do any kind of
protocol on them no I get like Body Work
once a week and stuff like that but no
like hand stuff crazy like a guitar
player right where it's like it's like
so
critical I don't like to get my hands
wet actually cu
you don't want to get your skin soft you
know I mean like if you get all pruny
like if you're in a hot tub I always hot
tub with my hands out of the hot tub
which I know sounds totally stupid but
that's actually pretty common for
climbers cuz it makes your skin so soft
and like you can't you can't grab the
edge of a knife with soft skin I have a
weird I have a weird like similar phobia
of like lotion like oh yeah yeah I'm a
hard with our daughter my wife has to
apply all like creams and lotions and
things I'm like I do not touch any I'm
100% with you I'll change diapers I'll
do all the things I'm just not doing the
lotion like you know like when my wife's
out of town I'm just like well bad news
she's knocking any of the things you
want on her until you get back you know
that's the other weird thing you're to
fight about kids like the first kid
you're like boiling the boiling the
freaking bottles and making sure that
the Caps had been by your like I got
four kids by the fourth kid it was like
I think it'll live like it just like
eating mud by the fourth one you're like
if the first one doesn't feed him I
guess he'll just be hungry exactly I'm
tired that's the way it goes down
man uh awesome man well hey thanks for
joining us man after after watching you
and following you and seeing you for so
many years uh it's it's really awesome
to sit down here and talk to you and
thanks for inspiring so many people and
sharing your experiences your Lessons
Learned and thanks for what you're doing
every day to help people around the
world and make the world a better place
man appreciate it oh thank you yeah
appreciate
it and with that Alex honold has left
the building after another what's it
been hour and a half of talking hour we
should have just kept I don't know you
just little other topics come up and you
just carry on
with uh trying to learn and trying to
understand and he's asking questions
about stuff and I think maybe he felt
like he didn't want to interview me when
we when we were actually on the podcast
so uh but man very very cool and you
know man really just like the it's not
too often you get to meet someone that's
at the Pinnacle of their world you know
they're at the Pinnacle of their world
doing things
that no one's done before by the way no
one's done since you don't see people
just rogering up to just go jump on that
gig again and just super nice super
humble super good dude man awesome yeah
I think that it was or one thing that
stood out that was interesting after
hearing it and then thinking about it
more was you know how he was talking
about hey I don't I don't want to get
he's like I'd rather stare death in the
face and not get hurt every day you know
ra you know that's better I I remember
thinking dang I think I'm literally the
exact opposite I would rather get like
spraining fingers and you know this and
that and not have to stare death in the
face every single you know um but at the
same time what that illustrates is like
okay this guy obviously like thinks and
looks at things like in a way different
way than maybe me or the very least me
but I think most people are like that
I'd rather get bumps and bruises than
have to look at death like life or death
like that um but it kind of offers like
okay this is a different way of looking
looking at things if I look at if since
I don't look at it like he looks at it
what am I missing in I don't know life
or whatever like what am I missing here
and then so when you listen up you can
kind of find out things that you never
would have really thought about ways to
look at stuff yeah it is interesting too
like when we got we were just downstairs
and we were all looking at our hands
looking at each other's hands and like
his hands are M are mutated yes like he
kind of denied it in here a little bit
yeah but then down there your tendons
grow right and he's been doing this
since he was 10 years old thousands and
thousands and thousands of hours of
pressure so his hands are definitely M I
wanted to like
like uh give him things to squeeze like
give him like tests you know what I mean
right want to give him like like hey
here's a grip strength test thing I want
to do that I want to try this I want to
see how long so I kind of wanted to see
what that was all about I was going to
be like Hey cuz you know when you you
know when he first came up I was like
hey good to meet you whatever shook my
hand he didn't like squeeze my hand he
didn't do nothing was normal and then it
wasn't until he was talking I was
like freaking you know how you can tell
like I said and I kind of mentioned it
where it's like okay Jiu-Jitsu guy this
guy's been in Jitsu he's been in all the
hard battles you're going to see on his
body you're going to see remnants of
those battles his ears his hands his
face a lot of the time um and him right
he's in the same exact boat so it's like
okay but where's his where were those B
where are those battles where is he
wearing them and then you look at his
hand and it's actually not really his
whole hand it's just his fingers when
you look at it like this part of his
hand like look at Dean List's hand it's
his whole hand it's like a freaking
abnormally huge like two mints right him
Alex's hand is like normal but his
fingers are all like to me they look
like big muscles on his fingers yeah but
and it makes sense tooo where you're
just holding cuz like consider this so
when I got in when I got real more into
lifting weights right and I have a twin
brother genetically um identical MH and
I got into Lifting for like years after
you know like after college and stuff
like that and then I remember and he
kind of stopped a little bit and I
remember this was after years maybe five
six seven years I remember like we made
a fist and he made a fist next to mine
and his fist was like way smaller than
mine his whole fist but I'm like oh this
is just from just lifting you know so it
like happens now Alex hell does the same
exact thing it's just his fingers though
so they're like all hug times starting
at 10 years old yeah yep very impressive
you know uh I was getting neck surgery
and the doctor you have to go through
the doctor he's got to tell you the
risks and he's like hey you know you
could get paralyzed you could get killed
you could whatever right tell me all
these things I go doc what I mean what
are the chances what are you talking
about like how many I said how many
sides are on this dice like
10,000 MH and he goes like
200 and I was like hm I I wish I would
have asked that to Alex like when you're
doing the the boulder
problem at 1,800 ft like
obviously there's mistakes that could
happen like how many times would you
have to do that how many sides are on
the dice where you like go to kick your
foot across and it catches on your pant
leg for a half a second and that's it
you know whatever the case may be so and
uh yeah man the the margin of error like
how big is that box you know you when
you read the book you definitely read
the book he talks about that like about
how different
situations his mindset is like yeah the
margin of sure it's a catastrophic
result mhm but the margin of error like
you can he could make a lot of mistakes
before something goes wrong but also
it's hard to
translate when you put your shoe your
rock climbing shoe on the
Rock like like I said I'm beyond I'm
below a novice in rock climbing I've
like done it and had fun whatever but I
it never feel it never felt like secure
to me like I can't imagine being 500
feet with my foot on a ripple and that's
got all my body weight yeah that yeah
it's it also shows you and we did talk
about this a little bit but like the
amount of technique that is involved
is it's just like every sport man it's
like every sport is so Reliant upon
technique and if you don't have
technique well not every sport but
there's so much technique to most sports
and some some like we talked about some
of them are real obvious that there's
technique some of them you don't see the
technique boxing you don't you look if
you know boxing you know how much
technique is involved if you don't know
boxing it just looks like you're
slugging it out with another human then
you go get in a ring with somebody that
knows how to box dude you're getting
worked worked rock climbing like I said
I I thought man I can do freaking 200
pull-ups in a workout this would be no
problem fre I was pathetic when I
started rock climbing
pathetic it was it was weird and
actually we were just talking downstairs
we were talking to that big dude who
Rock climbs Grant yeah and Grant's like
yeah you know it's I get a big pump my
arms and Alex is like well look you've
got the same basic size fingers as me
you have to hold 200 whatever pounds and
I only have to hold 162
lbs imagine you and I do a a a deadlift
contest and I have to deadlift 135 and
you have to deadlift freaking 315
for reps who's going to win well I'm
going to win I only have to dead 135
it's like of course y so man so much
stuff going on uh very cool to see what
the human being is capable of the the
mindset it was interesting too he said
his Advantage when he said psych I
thought he was going to say
psychological no he's like psych like
fired up he's like the psych cuz I want
to climb I want to do it all the time I
want to try hard problems I want to
figure them out that is his biggest
Advantage how glorious is that my
biggest Advantage is I'm just freaking
really into this yeah super psyched
about this
so very cool the human being capable of
a lot of things
uh let's see what we're capable of let's
push the envelope a little bit de reset
how's the de reset going for you well
good I'm on the path if that's what you
mean look am I doing the actual de reset
well actually I am actually
write anything down I got to write stuff
down check the boxes yeah I don't have
that thing but if I when I go through
the list of stuff I got to do I've been
doing that yes okay yeah get up early
you know I've been getting up early cuz
you text me I'll text you right back
right there in the morning you like that
don't you yeah kind of yeah um but
anyway it's going well thank you for for
asking we we I did a little workout with
K Dog the other day got on film nice fil
it have you done any of uh Jason kala's
workouts yet no good little metcons bro
throw them in there I know throw in
there yeah I I want to so every time I
do mine like you know how like so I'll
do rounds I told you what I do and I do
rounds and I write it on uh on the wall
with chalk you know like each round or
whatever so I'll take a picture of the
chalk rounds and I'll send it to Jason
I'll be like full credit today six
rounds full credit and like bro get on
the app do I'll give you this and that
and I'm like cool cool and but I never
got around to it I will though yeah but
yes I will I hear good things yeah the
train hard app check that out Jason kipo
they're they're good freaking workouts
and they're not you know what's cool
about them they're actually really good
for de reset because they're like
complimentary to whatever you're doing
they're like oh for 13 minutes whatever
nine minutes like you're going to do
something you're going to get a good
workout uh one of my deaf reset things
is 100 burpees a day yeah and yeah let's
just
say it's not fun every day it's full
credit I that's like a like that's such
a good Benchmark that and even the way
you structur it is actually really good
when you're like hey get 100 burpees or
what's the two it's 10 minutes of
burpees or 100 burpees whichever one
right exactly right well we're all we
all got it going on
um Chris Pratt's been getting getting
his death reset on which is cool getting
after it but so many people stepping up
making changes doing the right thing
eating clean fuel just awesome theede
reset.com check it out uh Joo fuel you
know we got what you need here's a
I got greens
creatine and throw a hydrate in there
this is like a tasty tasty tasty little
treat that that gets you the triple
threat yeah the triple production have
you done that before not with the greens
but my normal daily not daily every
single morning is the creatine with the
with Hydrate with hydrate yeah greens
too I'm just saying if you want to give
that a crack look bro I'm not I don't
like I'm not I'm not want to eat no
broccoli you know what I'm saying
broccoli so get the greens in anyways
joof fuel.com check it out ml we got
joint Warfare we got we got what you
need to fuel your system there's new
coffee MK by the way never mentioned
that are you into that cuz you never
were into coffee so coffee is not my jam
yeah as we like to say yeah that being
said I taste tested it because I'm
putting it out there so I'm at least
going to see what it tastes like and it
tastes freaking good yeah so my daughter
she's 10 by the way she was like um she
was like you didn't tell me you got new
coffee milk and she had been drinking
them I was like there's caffeine in that
thing 95 migam caffine that's still
caffeine and you know I'm not I'm not
giving my 10-year-old caffeine yet you
know but she's just pounding them
apparently she's like oh you didn't cuz
she likes coffee the flavor of coffee
she like drinks decaf coffee not all the
time but I'm like all right sister but
she approves of the even though she
can't do it anymore I kind of ban her
and she's unhappy about that but hey
honestly people life like anyone that's
into coffee Jamie like people just
freaking love they love that new MK the
M Coffee what is it sweet cream coffee
that's what it is it tastes good it's
got 95 milligrams of caffeine 30 gram of
protein this is basically the best
freaking breakfast a human can have am I
wrong you're not wrong because yeah cuz
that's it's a thing like people will be
like yeah I'm on this freaking I'm I'm
on the path I'm doing all this stuff I
start my morning with coffee but they
get the one from wherever with all the
creamy latte ventti like all the stuff
you the caramel maio or whatever it's
called and it's bro it jams your whole
[__] up it's like 500 calories on that
one so yeah and so you're off the path
just right in the like as you start your
day you start your day off the path
right there see what I'm saying no
reason for this no reason for that not
anymore sure there you go check out the
new coffee if you like coffee you'll
love this you'll love it uh you can get
this stuff at Wawa at the Vitamin Shop
GNC military commissaries Apes Haner
Dash St in Maryland W wake Fern
shopright HB down in
TAS thank you my people in teas for
getting after that HB crushing same
thing with Meer up in the midwest
crushing thank you Harris Teeter
Lifetime Fitness Shields and small James
if you want to sell if you are at a gym
or you go to a gym or you own a gym
email JF sales jof fuel.com get jof fuel
to your people that's what we're doing
origin USA
by the way if you need americanmade
stuff which you do if you want to
support America if you want to support
American communities if you want to
support freedom in the world go to
origin
usa.com and get some Goods by the way we
got some good stuff that actually it
might not be on the website yet but it's
like it's there uh we got like a jacket
you know the kind of uh little puffy
jacket that everybody wears around you
know around the world yeah sure like
it's just the standard wear like hey
California New York arkans doesn't
matter where I go people are wearing
this type of jacket we have one now it's
freaking perfect it's so good to go um
yeah so we got that we made a vest with
it too yeah wait is there does that
style have like a name I I the closest
I'd say is maybe people call it like a
puffy jacket just puffy jacket but it's
the typical the big Outdoors companies
make them yeah yeah and everybody wears
them yeah yeah that dig it so if you
want one that's not made by slave labor
if you want one that doesn't ruin the
environment by dumping a bunch of
chemicals into the ocean if you want to
support
freedom for human beings in the world go
to origin usa.com check it out genes by
the way yes sir jeans look how many
pairs of jeans you
have me no people people in the
world two it's a lot well I don't what
everybody shoot I don't know I have uh I
don't know eight maybe you got eight
pairs of jeans bro yeah all yeah origin
jeans all in the rotation what is that a
lot that's a lot that's a lot yeah oh
for real yeah but okay hey look you
might not need eight pairs of jeans like
eeko Charles has going on in this world
hey I do a guy all right so we're all
good hey that's what we're doing making
stuff in America check it out hunt gear
training gear t-shirts boots just go to
origin usa.com check it out get some
Freedom it's true also Joo store it's
called Joo store for so discipline
equals Freedom we're representing on
this path whether you're on the death
reset or not even though you are you
want to represent on the path you want
to wear your shirt or hat or
hoodie or shorts by the way we got
shorts and we are uh we have socks
coming come on bro hey a lot of some
some of us choose to represent on
various levels see I'm saying and socks
that's just one level check and
available some soap on there some good
stuff on there check Jo store.com
there's also the shirt Locker which is
like hey if you want a new design every
month you can you sign up for this
subscription you get a cool new design
every month it's relevant there's layers
on these designs people seem to like it
check it out uh it's called the short
Locker yeah check out also if you need
some steak which you do yes you do need
steak check out colorcraft beef.com and
also check out Primal beef.com this is
the best steak you're going to get out
there and you know you need steak boy is
there anything better than a good steak
it's it's very hard to find something
it's very hard to find something better
than a good steak and if you want to get
the best steak go to Primal beef.com go
to colorcraft beef.com get some steak
let's go also subscribe to the podcast
also subscribe to Joo underground Jack
underground.com we just got done
recording one of those so check that out
we answer your questions we talk about
some adjacent topics that's what we're
doing over there we got a YouTube
channel subscribe subscribe to the
YouTube channel
subscribe C what is it click like
subscribe yeah what the like share like
sh share subscribe all that stuff hey
check out our YouTube channel we put
stuff on there origin USA check theirs
out jao fuel check theirs out Eon front
check their is out psychological warfare
Flipside canvas.com Dakota Myers got
cool stuff for you to hang on your wall
books obviously covered a book today all
alone on the wall by Alex honold with
David
Roberts freaking good book check it out
the new version has the
entire uh Ascent of lcap in there so
it's just it's just a crazy awesome book
to read also I've written a bunch of
books about leadership I've written a
bunch of kids books too way the warrior
Kid 1 2 3 4 five kids books Also Mikey
the dragons also extreme ownership
dichotomy leadership have Echelon front
it's a leadership consultancy we solve
problems through leadership go to
Echelon front.com for details going to
do something live right now for you Jack
Daniel You Know Jack Daniel yeah I know
iard Jack Daniel Hill he just sent me uh
he just sent me an email I'm gonna read
it to you it says impact we're Echelon
front a leadership consultancy we teach
Leadership Lessons Learned on the front
Echelon of combat thus the name these
Leadership Lessons were often Written in
Blood our mission is to pass on those
lessons so that they do not have to be
Rewritten in more blood end quote when I
tell that to clients I emphasize that I
know that sounds extreme however while
what they do in their human endeavor may
not be life or death what their people
are doing 40 plus hours a week isn't
just the job it's their
life furthermore in some instances your
ability to implement some of the lessons
we we teach could be the difference
between life and death and then Jack
forwarded a real world example and I'm
not going to go into it just for the
privacy of the client but a client was
in a real world life and death situation
they resorted to the principles that we
teach at Eon front and got the problem
solved and life was saved so that's what
we do Echelon front.com if you want to
know about our leadership consultancy
you can find out about it there we also
have an online line training
platform these Leadership Lessons that
we teach can keep you alive as I just
mentioned in critical moments can keep
your family alive can keep your friends
alive hopefully you don't need it for
that hopefully you can just use it to
increase your profit take care of your
people build your
relationships do better at work
go to extreme ownership. comom for our
online
training also if you want to help
service members active and retired you
want to help out their families gold
star families check out Mark Le's mom
mama Lee she's got a charity
organization if you want to donate or
you want to get involved go to Americas
mightywarrior33
[Music]
themselves again and also Jimmy May's
organization beyondthe
brotherhood. if you want to connect with
Alex he's on the
interwebs Alex hon.com he's on Instagram
Twitter and Facebook at Alex honold and
I'm on there as well I'm at Joo willink
Eko is at Echo Charles just watch out
for the
algorithm just just be careful of it you
it doesn't come with a warning sign by
the way when you log into social media
it doesn't say warning this could waste
your enti entire freaking day should say
that but it doesn't it just shows you
something that you really want to see
that's what it does doesn't say a
warning it just says hey this is
something you really want to see and if
you move your finger from the bottom of
the screen to the top of the screen it's
going to show you something else you
really want to see and if you do that
over and over again there goes three
hours of time don't let that
happen thanks once again to Alex honold
for joining us awesome to meet you man
very cool and also thanks to the men and
women in the military around the world
right now the world is a volatile place
right now and you are standing ready to
protect us also thanks to our police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service and our park
rangers hadn't talked about them I kind
of incl I include them when I say all
First Responders when I say law
enforcement yeah I'm talking about you
all Park Rangers but I'm also thinking
about right now talking to Alex the park
rangers I've been going to the state
parks and national parks with my family
for a long long time and have been
helped out in minor ways right maybe
directions maybe people got stung by
stingrays at some state beaches and
whatnot sure it happens you know what
I'm saying maybe we could use a little
extra water out on a hike so we get we
get some we've got some help along the
way so thanks to all of you and all
other First Responders for what you do
you keep us safe
here and we are thankful for that and
everyone else out there I got one more
quote from Alex honold I think it's
applicable to all of us he said my
comfort zone is like a little bubble
around me and I've pushed it in
different directions and made it bigger
and bigger until these objectives that
seem totally crazy eventually fall
within the realm of the
possible and look you don't need to risk
your life you don't have to free soul LC
cap or half doome
but I think it's safe to say that we can
all push a little further out of our
comfort
zone take some risks get uncomfortable
push the envelope and basically get up
every day and to some extent please
go and get after it and until next time
this is EO and Joo
out